[Music]
okay
ready
and
[Music]
what's the theme song to fraggle rock
that should be the opening
i love jim henson because he did um
labyrinth right
let's hear it for the nope nope that's
flashing for the man
what are you doing you're thinking of
you remind me of the baby what bait is
the baby with the power what power the
power of
who do you do why are you fast forward
against
it's very slow and sensual it's not that
quick not for me
i do truly believe that my first sexual
experience
was seeing david bowie's
dick through his pants in labyrinth that
was your first sexual experience
that was the first time i was like oh
that's a dick i think that was the first
time i was like oh i want to
have sex with a goblin king
and that's trended your whole life
really so like to me david bowie was the
hottest in labyrinth david bowie that's
my sexual fantasy
really does that make me and my lesbian
i mean it kind of looks like you
that's what i just make you a narcissist
his hair does kind of look like my hair
currently for those of you listening
that's interesting i know
everyone's sexual awakening was for
those of you watching my hair
is i've today i look like adam duretz
uh i did hook up and then when i was 18.
no big deal
do you know who that is nope just
laughing you don't know who adam dirtz
is he's the singer of the cat in crows
mr jeff i don't know who that is
what mr jones and me i know that song
but i wouldn't have known that i hooked
up with the singer of that
oh do you feel cool this is this is hot
gossip
benton i'm dropping some hot goss on the
opening of the podcast and you're just
over there rolling your eyes yeah i
don't think anyone's gonna pick that
story up that's it that's weekly how you
watch
i hooked up with adam durant's i think
he's gonna be how famous i am
okay let's see how i hooked up with adam
dirtz when i was 18.
he hooked up with courtney cox and the
woman on your shirt jennifer aniston i
think
are you trying to what are you doing
right now i'm losing my mind
i know sorry the headline will just read
whitney cummings and who
adam duretz you don't remember mr jones
and me
i was i was busy having collagen
look do you not remember the song oh i
know the song mr jones at me yes
do you remember anna begins to
just know the one song do you guys know
this what i'm talking about
you know the county crows right ben how
many crows you really did have a
traumatic childhood
next thing you're gonna say is you don't
know the dave matthews band no i know
that for sure
satellite in my yahai's
i'm in a wild mode today okay let's
i cannot believe you just want to blow
past the me hooking up with adam durant
i can't believe you wanted to use that
as like a cool thing
that's not a cool thing i know it's lame
i'm just saying it's
funny that i hooked up with adam durst
when i was 18 and now i look like him
why is that we were talking about david
bowie icon legend star and you're like
but also get what
[Laughter]
one guy who's not the guy from blues
traveler
yeah do you guys know another person who
i did
that's really hot gossip i dropped some
hot goss on the back yeah that's cool
i'll do more research and i'll be into
it adam duretz was
in the 90s like a god
okay focus okay fine benton's not
interested in what we're talking about
so we have to move on but you know what
someone is and that's what matters
a couple announcements we are going on
the road you guys are buying tickets
they like us they really like us
we're adding four shows in denver um
i think we just added we added a second
night so it's four shows total
at the lincoln lot wow dinner at the
lincoln lot is coming through
denver's like we need something to do
let's go to that lot
down the street there's a parking lot
that's the first show dude when i was in
high school i partied in lots
parking lots are actually really fun so
the yeah i spent a minute
in a walmart parking lot doing what we
just stood
singing mr jones and me busted singing
mr jones and me
october 4th and october 3rd is sold out
october 4th we added shows also
escondido california people keep asking
me where that is my answer is i have no
fucking clue but it's in the southern
part of california
we'll be at the at the drive-in at
westfield north county i believe it's a
mall
uh we'll be right next we'll be right
next to the wet seal
in between the toe ring kiosk and the
cell phone case kiosk
uh will be in cape cod massachusetts
these tickets are not moving as fast as
they should because i think i
i didn't know where cape cod was i
thought it was in rhode island for some
reason so i sent
my community the uh the text me app
818-239-7527 excuse me
uh i sent it to rhode island but it
turns out cape cod is in massachusetts
october 15th 2020 we're in cape cod
massachusetts cape cod is like a very
rich
place yeah isn't that where fish come
from fish sticks
cape cod fish sticks that thing is it
somebody i think fish takes a lot as a
kid
oh i love a fish stick a lot
new merch i love a fish tank i do we
have to keep going
i still can't believe you don't care
about my dally answers i i will care
later when i figure it out this is so
rude
october 16th we're in ridgefield
connecticut at the
sorry at the ridgefield playhouse ball
field the only time benton ray will ever
be on a ball field hey
that's not true hey i played baseball
and i got kicked off the team
why because i'm too fabulous i was
performing
in my head i was performing a scene from
batman
returns i was catwoman and literally
three people ran past me on i was
watching third base they ran past me all
scored
watching third base while i was
performing i was supposed to be
and they all scored and i was not
allowed to come back because you were
playing michelle pfeiffer oh i was too i
was fully like on the side like
for who myself i was bored and i needed
something to do
okay so that was a little disrespectful
i thought i mean at least if you're
going to be on a baseball field
for do a performance from a league of
their own at least again not with
getting it right
at least be on brand uh
are we gonna play baseball while we're
here no we're gonna play comedy
we're gonna do comedy for you guys but
the ball field is outside so you're not
in your cars
there's a 5 30 p.m show we just added an
8 30 p.m show that i believe is sold out
october 16th richfield
connecticut sorry my dog is snoring and
just to repeat the ball phil is outside
but he wanted you to know
the ball field is outside it's outside
we gotta make sure people know uh yeah
people know that it's not an indoor ball
film
i've never heard of that i don't know
what that is and neither do you you said
it
i said an indoor ball no you said just
so everyone knows the ball field is
outside no i mean like
you're such a you're in a benton's in a
mood today
he wore his jennifer aniston shirt on
purpose to make me feel ugly
so i am saying that because some of
these are drive-in shows where people
sit in their cars
but that's the one in escondido which is
somewhere in california just so you guys
know the driving shows will also be
outside you're not going to drive your
car
okay you are you're got me on a
technicality
technicality um
october 18 2020 we're going to be in
ocean port
new jersey concerts in the garden that
sounds bouja's hill hold on this is a
two sentence
announcement this is the the name of the
venue is two sentences long
concerts in the garden at blue grotto at
mon mouth park concerts in the
garden i want to know who owns this
gorgeous what's a blue grotto and it's
spelled b-l-u were you guys too busy to
add the e
that's someone's name this feels like a
weird lawsuit blue grotto
yeah uh monmouth park mon mouth
or mon muss oh don't mansplain me
my producer just mansplained me can you
believe that in this
climate how dare you
i was going to slam my blue light
glasses on down on the table
these are the expensive ones so i'm not
going to now i'm going to slam my
quip toothpaste down how could you i
would have busted brought to you by
quippe
i'm feminism brought to you by quick
anyway so come see us on tour we might
add some more shows
as well go on a road trip do the damn
thing grab your scarf grab your mittens
come to cape cod
grab your box i mean it's going to be in
october so it's going to be chilly
william i can't wait
it is going to be so chilly willy
there's no way
it's not going to be freezing cold so
that's my dream grab a picnic
bring a little basket grab your uh
go-gurt comedy with a chill
and your bagel bites bring a bring a
thermos full of chili
actually benton i facetime benton last
night i was like a little i had
definitely had a glass of wine
and i faced time between i was like
we're gonna get merch guns
oh yeah she was like we're gonna get i
was like do you mean t-shirt guns uh
cannons guns
to shoot t-shirts out of the crowd we
looked them up they were
16 they were white they were 1200
so i was like all right benton you're
gonna have to really work on your uh
left yeah i'm gonna get one of those
those chunkets for dogs and just want
the t-shirts i've been tossing with them
chuck it what did i call it a chunk
that's that's for bigger dogs
you don't know you don't you don't know
about that that's the ball deposit and
check it so we're gonna roll t-shirts up
and put them in those little
uh boomerangs to throw dog balls and
just but should we give people
if you wear merch to the show what
rewards whitney's the only person alive
that wants to give merch away instead of
sell it she's just like we're just gonna
let's just bring it and throw it out
there
yeah i don't understand the point of
charging yeah you wanted to go
go around the t-shirts clean your
windshields off or something like what i
just want to give everyone merge i don't
see the point of selling it
benton always tells me i leave money on
the table fine
i leave them with my sunflower seeds so
yeah if you wear merch though um
we'll weigh from a distance i'm in a
weird mood today um
this is gonna be a great show jennifer
goodwin is here my best
friend is on the show today i've really
been waiting to have her on the show i
wanted to wait for my birthday as you
guys know this is my birthday month
it's virgo season birthday month oh no
i'm that bitch i never used to celebrate
my birthday and as soon as i got into my
late 30s i'm now like it's my birthday
month we're celebrating every day that's
a lot 38 years old i'm wearing the shirt
that benton gave me for my birthday
right now for those of you not watching
go to youtube and see how ridiculous i
look i'm wearing
can you explain to people it is a
bubblegum pink
um i think it's a vintage horse shirt
with three horses on it
and then there's gold like what would
you call that
these are sequins there's gold sequins
like in a pattern around it
and the horse is crying blue tassels
there's tassels right like um
at my and the horse's heads are right
where my boobs are so if i
shake my boobs it looks like they're
galloping so yeah it's crying in 3d
and then oh yeah and then one of the
horses is crying which is like really
actually kind of a sad twist
it's just emotional it's not like it's
just so happy okay
thank you for this gift ben i really
appreciate it
um jennifer goodwin what did you think
of the interview that's coming up that
you guys are about to listen to
well i loved hearing about when you were
poor and helpless
because jennifer was my best friend when
i was uh i guess we became best friends
when i was 22 and i was
i was a broke girl i was one of the
broke girls
um and jenny was like my mom i just
loved hearing about you being poor
helpless because i'm only used to the
latter part of that sentence
um and being helpless and so hearing
about
hearing her like before you did stand up
she knew me before i did stand up like
comedy hearing someone talk about you
before you had any power was
very exciting wow because it's just like
she could like you had no power like she
could be like get out of this house and
you'd be like i don't have one to go to
i was truly homeless back when jenny and
i became friends i have no idea
why she stayed friends with me it's it's
a it's a uh
i'm a real um whodunit uh
in terms of why she's friends with me
i'll never understand but i'm very
grateful and i'm so glad she came on
because there's i feel like we spent so
much time on this podcast talking about
edifying yourself being better healing
uh giving you guys all the wisdom that
i've collected from my litany of
therapists and healers and books and all
the
sort of stuff that i'm trying to collect
and give to you guys
but genie just has it very inherently
jenny's always
like i'm in therapy to think like jenny
and i don't
i don't is it a southern thing like i
think it might she just has
i have a theory that women in the south
this might get me canceled southern
women just
have this inherent wisdom
that women in other parts of the country
have to get elsewhere like we have to
watch ted talks and shit
and listen to podcasts like this or
whatever and like read brene brown books
like ginny always had this very direct
clear wisdom and
i think it might be all that time on the
porch
okay i'm just saying when i lived in
virginia you'd drive by and there'd be
like women sitting on the porch and i
was like what are they doing they don't
have air conditioning
that's why we're on the porch they were
they were passing on
ancestral wisdom from one generation
to every girl every every grandmother is
a brene brown do you know what i mean
sorry i have a hair in my mouth it's
really distracting is it yours
no i'm not sure whose it is um
no that's definitely not mine um it
might be my lovers
pubes the point that i'm trying to make
is that
she was not door like we talked my other
friend is dory but jenny
like was never crazy she just always had
it together my other theory about it
besides that they spent a lot of time
with their grandmother i never saw my
grandmother growing up
i never got my grandma's wisdom like she
lived in a different place
calm down i'm just saying i didn't get
granny wisdom and i feel like in the
south
there isn't the same kind of ageism and
people spend time with their freaking
grannies you know and they get all that
advice
like uh this is some granny wisdom i
think it was one of
i think it was one of ginny's
grandmothers that said um uh we try to
overthink relationships so much
and uh someone's grandmother said to her
always be with a man that loves you just
a little more than you love him oh yeah
that's some southern granny shit dude
only a 90 year old grandma in a
rocking chair like sewing a home is
where the hardest pillow
would be able to just know that
you know it's a savage piece of wisdom
dude it's just like sad that is a thing
people say in the sound
i also think that like southern women
the cooking
is a big part of how they develop this
sort of like
emotional ninja mindset you know like
like
if you can cook chip beef gravy you can
make a marriage
chip beef gravy yeah chip beef gravy
okay do you know about chip beef gravy i
don't think anyone does
chip beef gravy dude what do i know more
about southern cooking than you do it's
definitely not southern
i don't know what that is i'm just
saying if you have the patience to
pickle watermelon
you know how to ask for a raise you know
like the the
food preparation in the south i feel
like was also preparing you
for life if you can cut okra without
getting all that disgusting clear calm
all over yourself
you can get out of a bad relationship
okay i think you may be conflating
wisdom with the fact that southern
people just like talk to everyone like
they're their family they just go right
in
it's just how's your daddy doing you're
like man i don't know you this is tsa
wait are you saying that southern people
have more wisdom because they just talk
to people more
and gather wisdom just whereas
when i lived on the east coast you go
outside you don't talk to your cab
driver you don't talk to people
i mean it could be that or it's just the
fact that i think southern people just
treat everybody like their family
and and the way that they talk to you my
family
we're mean to each other no you're i
wouldn't want to try people
and so like and so i think that you just
tend to be like oh this person has so
much wisdom because they're talking to
me as if they do
and like and they don't have time to
complain like everything is just face
value you have what you have but it's
just like and also some people don't
have time to complain
you don't have time to complain you have
things to do it's really true
and you can't very there's just too much
shit to do you have too many lawns to
mow yeah and you have to get you have
things to do and you also like this is
what you got you got what you got you
can't change it so
you can't complain about it so bad is
can you hear it
okay sorry guys my dog is snoring and
you can't change it because you you know
you have things to do
and you don't have i got the you got the
point of that right i left my truck at
time but
you lost my track of time yep i got roll
off track because what i wanted to say
was
southern people trick you they trick you
into solving your own problem
by the way the best part of i just what
did you just say
lost my track of time i just lost my
track of time
ben and i were talking last night about
how southern people have these like
like very cryptic that's what i'm
getting to experiments but it's just so
funny that you said i lost my
yeah i lost my time as we go
southern people make up fake
inspirational quotes yeah they're like
absolutely no sense and it's to make you
figure it's your own problem
you can ask anything you're like how's
the weather outside they're like well
three cats can't catch a mousetrap full
of rain and you're like i don't
really understand that but i'm gonna
figure it out on my own i guess but so
you're saying that southern people get
so wise because they use these
uh weirdly circuitous motivational
quotes that mean nothing so then you
have to figure it out on your own
yeah so it makes you wiser yeah keep
grinning like a pasta i'm eating a sweet
tighter and you're like
stay happy i don't i don't know what
that means and then and then if you get
it wrong we're just like why didn't say
that
so i'm like oh so that means i should
probably stay in the relationship i
didn't say that but whatever yeah yeah
but if the
the possum eating the sweet potato that
means i was i'm supposed to stay
positive right
sure yeah rather rather walk a mile in
piss-filled boots and stay here and get
shit on
so i shouldn't let him shit on me you
know what my boyfriend pisses on god has
a plan
okay got it so my
okay do i drink the piss in the boot i
don't know lying like a dog
it's just you know it's very like it's
just empty quotes and you're just like
oh yeah they're so
wise also the twang helps the twang if
you have a twang people automatically
you can say whatever you want to people
you look just like your daddy
you lost weight hollywood you want
weight watchers you are just
disappearing no but i feel like
growing up you also i think is when you
grow up in the south you get this
accidental support because everybody
says bless your heart
and you don't know until later it means
they think you're dumb
so i got a lot of like bless your heart
and i was like they're blessing my heart
they think of that like
and then now that i'm an adult i'm like
oh no they were being sarcastic and felt
sorry for me because they thought i was
dumb
yeah bless your hearts like a whole
language you can say it many ways it's
you know
there could there's good bless your
heart bad bless your heart
what's that mean bless her heart bless
her heart that's she's dumb
oh she's so dumb like that's her heart
oh bless your heart yeah there's a lot
of um
fake niceties but when you're a kid you
don't know they're fake so you're just
like god i'm getting all this love and
support and then you're an adult and
you're like oh
yeah southern people are real big on
like prayer circle we're going to pray
for her and just fully gossip
it's just she just lord she keeps
drinking her husband is cheating on her
and you know she wears them little
shorts they're so little lord like
it's when you're very much like what are
we doing
i love a southern woman i love southern
woman wisdom
um so jenny is going to share that with
our fans
is that exciting yeah she's good
southern um
people loved andrew huberman last week
doctor oh my god i'm so sorry doctor
if if i had a doctorate in something and
someone didn't call me a doctor
i would be so pissed off i would sue
them i truly would be like you only
address me as doctor
so sorry sir um you make us do that
anyway so it's so strange
here's the thing i i listened back
through it because i had to pull clips
or something i don't know why
um and i want to fix some things about
myself
on this podcast i interrupt too much i
get excited
don't you have a therapist for this i do
but she came in the podcast and i
interrupted but she can't get a word in
yeah she said i think you should but
listen to the next part of this so what
do you think about this
like i just i i i do think i might have
tourettes
okay bold statement i just
i get so excited when we get
we get such good guests on the show and
i just get so excited and i want to make
the fans happy and i want to ask them
all
the questions that i have written out
and sometimes i interrupt people and i
feel like it might be annoying
i mean i'm sure some people are annoyed
by it i'm sure some people are like what
how dare you
i'm sure some people are just like i
really want to hear the end of that
sentence but you know
i think the majority of the only ones
hear the punchline of that show yeah
damn it
i thought that person would get to talk
more but um you just had to
stand for neuroscientism and he said two
words
you know that's all we know about him um
but i just think that like
also people realize that in real life
real quick at least the conversations i
have
they're very just like we're gonna see
who can talk the most like who's gonna
get the most words that's how comics
talk first of all if you grew up in
alcoholic home it was just about and you
did and i did i don't know if you guys
the theme of uh my life is that you guys
know this but i've had a hard life
um no but i just mean i'm used to having
to fight for air time
with comics certainly that's just sort
of how we
talk and then when non-comedians come on
i i
was like oh my god you're used to people
letting you finish your sentence
yeah you think this is a ted talk i'm
like wait a second hold on you think
that i'm gonna ask a question and then
listen when you answer no no i just want
to hear the question
i just want to hear myself ask the
question yeah you're just here for this
is this is fluff
um but i mean that is true also like as
a comic you're always like thinking like
i can put a joke there that's funny i
could put a joke there i can get you
know
and you're like trying to move this
thing that you're thinking along
where the other person's just like i
thought he wanted me to answer this
question
you know what else i do that i hate i
say
i go uh-huh like i'll yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
right
right right
where are you going are you having an
orgasm yeah
i finally found out what makes me have
an orgasm somebody question and support
no i i i was or this i was listening to
podcasts
over the weekend beca from one of the
next guests coming on to do some
research because i really do work hard
on this podcast you guys um contrary to
what you said
and i heard a podcast host where
who was agreeing with the person and it
was so fucking annoying
she was like yes uh-huh um totally and i
was like i hope i never do that's active
listening we're taught to do that
but it's fucking obnoxious in an audio
podcast
i need to shut my whore mouth more yeah
you want you you want to think she died
till she talks again
i'm no i just i don't need to hear you
agree
silently in your head you can nod your
head nod
right like just get over yourself dude
you don't need to be involved when
someone else is talking
it doesn't need to be about you all
would you like it better if it was like
this like
did you tell me about something but but
for audio or for video absolutely
completely but also howard stern
arguably one of the greatest
interviewers ever right
he uh he's given
the few interviews he's given he talks
about how the reason he's such a good
interviewer is if he gets bored
he knows the audience is bored so he's
not going to let someone finish their
sentence if he's getting bored he'll
just cut them off and talk about
something else
so i'm just it's good to give that trick
away so everyone knows that you think
they're boring
i like that you're telling it here now
guys if i've ever interrupted you it's
because i think you're boring as shit
i don't think you're bombing you're
ruining my podcast you're gonna go back
and be like and she interrupted here and
she interrupted here and looked right
here
fuck uh i'm gonna be canceled for so
many reasons
this week um i did stand up for the
first time
in six months seven months seven months
seven months i did stand up on
abc the american broadcasting company
owned by disney
uh what is this announcement i'm just
telling
do you work for them now uh kevin hart
was the host
uh will ferrell chris rock etc we talked
about this last week on the opening yeah
you did you wrote with all your jokes i
read the jokes
uh it went great i miss doing stand up
so much
um but most of the jokes i told will be
cut because i said
as i said it was on the disney network
yeah you just became a warm-up
they were just like oh well um it airs
september 14th
and here's i'm gonna i'm gonna make you
a bet on the podcast right now
watch it on september 14th i i bet you
equip toothpaste are they still sponsor
i bet you equip toothpaste and
toothbrush
truly we can send we can whoever
we'll figure it out okay dm benton for
details of this
competition i just invented um these are
the two jokes they're gonna cut
ready because it was so special about
voting
you guys need to vote supreme court
justices are at stake our rights are on
the line
but still people will say voting is such
a hassle you know it's a hassle driving
your girlfriend 350 miles across state
lines to plan your family
is that clearly an abortion joke
absolutely
okay i didn't say the word abortion what
did you think it was when you wrote i'm
just saying i very cleverly
tiptoed around the word abortion i i
i didn't see she was the a pregnant
girlfriend yeah don't say pregnant
i just said your girlfriend 350 miles
across state lines to plan your family
they could be going to get birth control
they could you're right that is that is
funnier
i'm just saying so i was arguing with
them afterwards because they're like
yeah we have to cut this are you trying
to trick disney she's like but listen
listen listen
just me fighting with a cartoon mouse
and then
this one i know they're gonna cut and i
knew they were gonna cut it go again
people don't want to talk uh too oh
people don't want to hear about
celebrities talk about voting yet they
will talk about voting with their crazy
uncle who's trying to convince everyone
on facebook
that the animated disney castles are
made of dicks
and then i said if you guys cut that
joke it's
true if you cut that joke q anon is
right
i am torn though this special comes out
on september 14th on abc
and i really want to do it because i
just i miss doing stand up so much and
going on the tour i just want to make
sure that i'm sharp i'm sharp
i'm not i don't want to be rusty but
like i
half the jokes that i did were about how
annoying it is when celebrities tell
people how to vote
like what are we gonna do are
celebrities supposed to tell people to
vote or not is it obnoxious
or is it helpful ben and i always argue
about this and
part of the reason we argue so much is i
don't have an opinion yet i'm still
my opinion is up for grabs on this on
one hand i want celebrities to shut
their hormones when it comes to politics
on the other hand
it's like you need to use your platform
responsibly like i i don't
i don't know where i land yet yeah and i
just have uh all the opinions
so i mean i think that when you have a
platform you do have to use it i think
i think we are demanding that of people
now i think that we're done with the
time of like you get to be
a scumbag and famous like we're not
doing that anymore yeah but there's a
lot of actors
that are not qualified to weigh in on
this shit like
i it does get a little bit annoying when
someone that like played a doctor on
house thinks they're a doctor and
they're going to tell me
about how kovid works like right we're
not saying that they're smart
we're saying this is a this is a game of
teams and i need you to get this message
out to everyone that you can because
you're on my team i see so but
but maybe it's just how you do it
because i don't like being lectured oh
yeah that's great by
actresses on how to live and on science
it's like i think a lot of actors
and actresses are starting to think that
they are the roles that they've played
in television shows just because you
played a scientist on csi
doesn't mean you know about the covet
vaccine yeah and that's on that's on
fans a lot just because you're on west
wing doesn't mean you can tell
me about politics like you read lines
that someone else
wrote yeah and i mean that is is on the
fans for giving them that like
power surge and making them think that
way i think but i mean the end of the
day like
what you're saying is right like i don't
want you
there's a time and a place to talk about
voting and it's not here's my thing i
think well i think a lot of celebrities
when they tell people to vote
they're saying vote as long as you vote
like me oh for sure as long as you're
voting for the
teams yeah so i'm fine with celebrities
saying register to vote vote but i'm not
fine with them telling you how to vote
yeah i mean i mean i just my biggest i
get the most upset about it whenever you
like ruin something for me
so here's this is ben tonight this is
one of our first conversations that made
me think that benton had to be in my
life and help me build my brand
is that benton has such an incisive take
on
celebrities role and what they should
provide
to their fans when because i spend so
much time
being like oh i don't want to like seem
like a narcissist
as you can tell i don't want to seem
like a narcissist she hates her yeah i
just hate attention
give me a microphone and get off stage
um i'm just saying like
i've spent so much time being like oh
god this is self-indulgent i don't want
to post this this seems like i'm
bragging this seems like
i think i'm better than somebody like i
want to be humble i want to be
you know um people to know what did you
just give me a thumbs up no you did that
i gave a thumbs up to my producer i'm
sorry benton i'm
running a podcast i'm just talking i'm
giving
really insightful i just thought it was
cute and i wanted information
and i'm multitasking it's called
multitasking
aren't you producer you're such an
asshole he's literally lighting me
because we've been talking for two and a
half hours
we're just rambling listen i'm trying to
get to the point of the fact that i
i i know you're gonna make this point
badly because i know you no i'm not
yes you are because i think you'll go
from bitterness insightful to you can't
make a point guys
this is how pension is benton will make
such an amazing cogent point or say
something super hilarious and then i'll
ask him to repeat it and he'll totally
jumble it and fuck it up
a lot of pressure um okay i'm gonna push
the microphone away from my mouth and
i'm not gonna interrupt you because it's
new year new me
it's the same year um i might be
like old school and thinking about this
but like to me celebrities are supposed
to be like
almost otherworldly they're supposed to
be something that you like i want to
achieve or they're they're not supposed
to be like an everyday person
you're making a point which is that you
want celebrities to
be larger than life you want to the idea
is i think celebrities now
they it's insane famous by being larger
than life and then they're like but i'm
just like you yeah that's insulting we
don't want you to be just like since the
social media but i got these pillows
from target well bitch you didn't have
to
and i don't want to hear about it i have
pillows from target
who's who's supporting gucci like that's
how i
like think like want you to be like me
i'm like me all my friends are like me
you be something different and so
anyways yeah if i want to see pillows
from target
yeah i'll go there they they let me in
so
like i could afford pillows from target
like my thing yeah and so like when you
all get together you all i'm just
throwing you in there
um i don't see myself as a celebrity no
i'm like a hero more of a character yeah
you're like an icon legend
i feel like i'm just more of like a role
model than anything but like nobody
hates hollywood more than
hollywood and they'll get together and
ruin everything for you you ever watch
the oscars you all plan it together
you're with your friends you have your
sandwiches named after actors or
whatever you guys do at your parties
and then that movie you love wins and
that celebrity gets there and they're
like
guys voting is so important right now
and like none of this
yeah like none of this matters it's like
you motherfucker
you're like i wanted that's the biggest
thing when they go none of this matters
i was like
they leave trade me what are you talking
about
like i said we've been here all day
waiting for this movie to win we wanted
you to tell me did you like the movie
was it fun what was the audition like
did you enjoy the role
and you're gonna get up here and tell me
you hate all this
get the fuck out of here this kind of
blows my mind
i hate that bullshit or or when they're
giving an interview and they're like
award season's coming up they're like oh
i have to sit in all the hair and the
dresses and i had to try on 40 gallons
shut the hell up
we worked three jobs to afford the cable
bill to watch this
and you're gonna tell me you don't
coming in with the points and you're
gonna tell me that you don't want to
try on 14 custom-made gowns give them to
me i can't even fit them and i'll take
them
like this is boy i hate that shit i hate
that you're also discouraging you can't
you can't want us to respect your craft
and to respect you and then
simultaneously shit on your entire
business
and it's it's giving a very bad message
to people who are to kids or
actors or whoever in the fucking glee
club whatever they're doing that's like
looking up to you
and then you're just like well when you
when you achieve all this it all
sucks then why do we want to do it yeah
it's so true
like on one hand they'll give an oscar
speech and they'll be like if i can do
it anyone can
i came from nothing and this business is
horrible yeah like what you can't be
like oh this business is the worst watch
my movie it comes out in september like
yeah
what should i do do i watch it or not i
think everyone's so desperate to be
relevant
and people have realized that
complaining makes them relevant and
being political makes them relevant
i think that people are inflated yeah
having depression makes me relevant
everybody needs to publicly brought they
think they need to publicly broadcast
their flaws
uh to be interesting or to stay relevant
but here's what's relatable you know
what's relatable
if if if an everyday hard-working person
got the opportunity to to be in movies
or
or to win those awards what would be
relatable
is celebrating that being happy and
excited that's why we like cardi b
and liz though because these are people
that were just like us and now they have
something more and they're excited about
it they're enjoying it
every time they put out a song they do a
video they get on instagram they talk to
a fan they're enjoying it that's so
that's what
that's what a hard-working person they
enjoy their rewards if you
worked at the piggy wiggly if you were
at the piggly wiggly and then you got
promoted to the manager
from the pickle you'd have a barbecue
with your family and celebrate you
wouldn't be like
oh god my promotion you wouldn't do that
yes
you can be rich and famous and not be a
piece of shit
and you don't have to and you also have
to be just like me to be relatable
believe it or not i can relate to you
you're being happy i can do that
we're not all you don't have to be
miserable like it very much comes off
like celebrities are like
oh you know the rest of america they're
just so depressed because they're not us
so i have to be depressed too
yeah like no i have to also have anxiety
well it's a
it's like it's so shut up this is why i
love ben and so much he has
all the fucking points and you know it's
just so
interesting to me because i'm always
trying to go like okay
what do i do with my platform you're
going to be you people are going to be
mad at you whether you're
sure right yeah so but ariana huffington
um she did this think tank i don't even
know what you call it
a study how about that where
they found that people only change their
behavior if someone they admire
changes their behavior so
celebrities behaving a certain way and
it works
you know and then tell us all the time
that's why we put you on cereal boxes
and shit
totally but it's it's basically like
just be a good example don't tell us
what to do just do it
and we'll decide if we want to
participate or not yeah actions speak
louder than words
post a photo of yourself saying on my
way to the polls instead of
vote like your life depends on it
because it does like jesus
like or vote like you care about people
who are blind and you're like
i do like what are you talking about my
aunt's blind
yeah it's like stop like like why are
you yelling at us like
if you if if you're in the public eye
and i'm following you
and you're living a certain way i'll
notice you don't have to tell me what
you're doing yes yes yes you don't have
to be like but aren't i the best but i
love it when
when celebrities lecture good people on
how to be good people think no we're
good people yeah a lot of people
you're the weirdo disgusting pedophile
selfish monsters that are causing all of
that a lot of celebrities fly private
and are ruining the fucking environment
a lot of celebrities are trained to be
nice and not be good um
there is a difference isn't there yeah
there's a difference of being nice i
think that celebrities forget that
they're hired by the people that they're
lecturing
so they're like you guys need to vote
it's like we already paid
20 to see your shitty rom-com last year
like we were right
we're why you're famous why are you
yelling at us yeah and it's like you
should work for us
that's that's my thing about celebrities
comedians we work for you
you guys are the boss you decide so when
someone wants a picture with me in an
airport you're gonna get a fucking
picture if you download my special or
watch my special now to be clear that
does not mean that you own that person
they're not your property they have they
do get to have opinions and thoughts and
stuff
but the difference is you're not
superior to the people that that pay
money to see your movies
that's right that i'm not better than
you like thank you there's just this
gratitude
lack of gratitude to people's fans like
people now talk down to their fans like
their children that's what bothers me
yeah they do
and and that's the difference in being i
think this new version
of celebrity that we have that are
people like lizzo and them that have
that have worked to get where they are i
get it
more than me or versus i mean youth work
too or versus someone who has like
kind of been born into that and is a
celebrity that's two very different
ways they treat people it is interesting
that people i just i'm always obsessed
with human nature you know but um
that's me guys i'm just thinking you
know me i'm just like a doctor um
doctor uh what are you doing i'm trying
to get my hair is there something living
in there so touching it be an acceptable
way if you guys aren't watching on
youtube right now i'm being real well
um i guess it's just like it's amazing
where we draw the line
on taking advice from celebrities you
know like we want
we want health advice we want makeup
advice we want sex advice we want
relationship advice but voting like
that's where we draw
take a vacation during that season how
about that you get the whole rest of the
year
every four when it comes down to this
you just calm down you bow out i should
i
argue that we should not take health
advice or parity advice from i think we
should
parenting advice no i it drives me nuts
when i see a celebrity parent that's
like i don't let my kids
on screens it's like yeah because you
have three nannies what the fuck are you
talking about and also by the way
you're on screens all the fuck that
drives me nuts when a celebrity is like
i don't let my kids on screens meanwhile
she's on fucking instagram stories all
day long and you see the kid in the
background
being like mama i'm hungry yeah it's
like go baby
you're on screens all day it's like who
are these strangers and uh
yeah it's just i mean it's like they're
like yeah i don't put my kids on screens
they're too busy in the scientology
center where they should be
you know learning the future it's very
learning about real science yeah
it's very much like i don't want to know
about your child care tips until you
tell me how to get your job because i
can't achieve one without the other
oh interesting you really like to know
how people got worthy i do
i i will read every biography and get my
hands on oh i hate it when celebrities
give out health advice like don't
take health advice from celebrities like
my crystal's healed me
i'm like okay my crystals are why i'm
not stressed out you sure it's not the
fucking xanax
sure it's not true it's not the fact
that you work a month a year
in new zealand maybe that's why you're
not stressed yeah i want to know what
fillers you didn't get
not how to live a minimalistic life
okay we're rambling we gotta get to
ginny
i love talking to you benton but wait
what
the gender reveal bomb that exploded
near your home i know hot news not near
your home
we've got some hot true news we've got
some true news coming in hot
many were evacuated from their homes
after gender reveal bomb sets many a
wildfire
wow i added many others on cuter gender
agenda there was a gender reveal part in
california they did a smoke bomb
caught california has become so liberal
that if you believe there are two
genders you'll just
spontaneously combust right
it's also like the only time you should
be using a smoke bomb at a baby shower
is if you or that baby plan on
disappearing i don't understand the
obsession with gender
reveal like i just don't the only thing
more annoying than that actually is when
people
don't want to know the gender and people
are like i just i don't know i just
we're not gonna we don't know we're we
want to be surprised aren't there enough
surprises in childbirth
like this fires we're a surprise huh i'm
just saying like
why would you want to i at least i do
support knowing before you give birth i
have so many friends
like we don't know i'm like what color
are you painting your baby room fucking
moss green
yellow you don't know what to get the
kid i don't know what to buy them
you know maybe i'm participating in like
conditioning and social construction but
i'm just like i don't know what to buy a
kid if i don't know it's gender
yeah you should only have gender reveal
parties if they're for yourself i and
also wait with the way
with what things are the way things are
going i'd wait to do your gender reveal
party till the kid's like 15 or so yeah
let them decide have their own party
maybe they don't want to park maybe they
don't maybe
show about it it was a smoke bomb gender
reveal right
it was uh yeah like the big ones like
the ones that lifted off like a lot of
smoke not like the ones we had that were
like
like when i was born we didn't have
smoke bombs at the gender reveal
uh everyone was just actually smoking
cigarettes
it's a girl
that's very much what they used to give
up doctors were smoking yeah that was
the doctor giving the advice
could you imagine believing in the
gender binary so much that you just set
the world on fire
you're just like i'm about to prove a
point pink or blue yeah
burn it all down right like what is your
baby lucifer
how did you start the apocalypse like
her walking away from the car and
waiting to exhale
they just throw their baby i'm just
saying like gender reveal parties creep
me out
am i the only one that it's basically a
party where
it's like is it a tiny penis or a tiny
vagina yeah it makes me think about tiny
genitals
am i a pedophile i mean that's weird um
okay we gotta get to jennifer goodwin
because
her interview is a delight it's full of
wisdom
lols she really shared a lot of things
that she has never shared publicly to my
surprise and delight yeah sure they
walked the line
i hate you you're fired i don't know
what your job is but you're fired from
it
um uh
birthday 818-239-7527 and giving updates
on tour dates because things
are crazy there's a lot of rigmarole out
there shows get canceled they get moved
they get
masked they get unmasked they get in
they get revealed
i'm just saying things might change
weather might be crazy like just let's
keep
in touch text me please so that i can
give you guys updates in case
you know yeah get tickets to cape cod
come share a fish stick with us
yeah we don't know either um do you have
any other knives we have new merch
coming out in a couple weeks
okay it's new we've been working on it
for a minute and it is pretty good
it is i mean if you liked our old merch
forget about it because this is better
and it's all free and yeah and it's not
free um
also like subscribe to my youtube
channel i'll start doing giveaways on
the podcast i got excited
did you notice that yeah what do you
just text me at 3am and said we're
giving away thanksgiving every friday
i want to start doing real giveaways
about valuable things to subscribe to
the youtube channel so we're going to
find something valuable first
i i found out that my nemesis has more
subscribers than me and i got motivated
oh okay anyways
so that was dark jennifer
german elephants don't plagiarize me
we now take a break in our regular
scheduled programming
what's his voice it's called being
sexual ever heard of it
i don't think so you're not attracted to
me when i do this
um are you yeah but we are taking a
break to talk about hellofresh
hellofresh i'm obsessed with hellofresh
you know what hellofresh is fresh
pre-measured ingredients
seasonal recipes delivered right to your
door number one meal kit in america
honestly this is the greatest invention
we talk about like putting a man on the
moon electric cars
yeah deliver a man to your door deliver
a man to my door
holding hello fresh that is the ultimate
aphrodisiac
makes home cooking easy also fun and
affordable but easy
is the most important time to me they
deliver all the ingredients
to your doorstep cuts out like the
planning and having to go to the grocery
store and the freaking
you know what every time i go to the
grocery store as i said that i knew
when i go to the grocery store you just
get dips i go to the grocery store
and i black out when i get there yeah
you literally just get dips and crackers
well because i don't know what i'm going
to want to eat in four days
and then i'm like i don't know what
ingredients or yeah so i just buy like
five sauces and i get home and i was
like
like the grocery store is too
overwhelming for me and
i always grocery shop with an empty
stomach the point is
hello fresh is amazing it's it's easy
it's so bad
you know when you're like oh i'm gonna
make some food and you're like but i
don't have that one ingredient yeah like
it's crazy fast and
everything is delicious i think i've
been through every recipe at this point
i know i mean and it's amazing i mean
i've not disliked anything i like the
vegetarian ones
i was really feel good about myself they
have like this texas mac and cheese oh
that's
that one is so good that one is so good
and it's all just pre there's no way you
can be a bad cook yeah you really can't
mess it up unless you like leave the
house
you can't mess it up unless you're me
and you just walk away yeah let's just
walk away take a bath like
walk away from a burning stove and then
somebody will come right in and fix it
so don't even worry
keep your fridge stocked by adding extra
proteins or sides like garlic bread oh
my god the garlic bread is so good
to your weekly order easy change for
your delivery days or food preferences
skip a week whenever you need they're
flexible
feeding the whole family has never been
easier or just feeding yourself
with large box sizes for more servings
and more
savings uh they also give back we're
living in a nightmare
and any company that gives back i really
appreciate go to hellofresh.com
good for you 80 and use code good for
you 80 to get a total of 80
off including free shipping on your
first box
hellofresh.com good for you 80 and use
code good for you 80
to get a total of 80 off including free
shipping on your first box
additional restrictions apply please
visit hellofresh.com for more details
this will make men want to marry you
hello fresh hello husband
best fiends i'm obsessed with this best
fans
best fiends we're in a full-on
competition
well i just i'm like sick of watching
television i'm sick of like
googling myself i'm sick of checking
instagram
i love to play with characters that kind
of look like me
and they're all you don't look like
they're also like they're like
what would you it's a game it's like a
thing it's a game you're correct yeah
i'm just saying it's a game
on your iphone that you can just play
and it's like the perfect balance of
like
fun but it's also like there's something
soothing about it and there's yeah
there's it's very soothing because you
feel like you're achieving something
that's it
and it's also kind of good for your
brain it's like a puzzle it's like a
puzzle but it's also the things are cute
it's not i don't like video games that
are like
about killing hookers and stealing car
i'm just like they're it's just like too
upsetting this one is just like cute and
fun and like
i don't go into a blind rage when i'm in
it
yeah but you can also compete with
friends and i like that i love the
competition aspect of it
yes and it's a puzzle i mean it's
basically like a puzzle
game it is like a puzzle game but
there's like some strategy to it because
it's not like
it's not just like oh here's a line i
have to make you can do swirls and
like it's like myself like like playing
at such weird times like if i just have
like 10 minutes between things like i
don't even meditate anymore i just like
play best fiends yeah i'm i can't stop
because i it's very reward based you can
like get other little creatures and
other trophies
and i love anything that ends in a
reward so i'm like really competitive
with myself you don't need the internet
to play which is good because i find
it's like a good thing to do when you're
like i don't want to be on my phone
looking at the news
getting upset and having panic attacks
from reading headlines
but i do want to engage my brain in
something and entertain myself so
you do not need the internet to play
which is part of the reason i love best
fiends oh so you don't have to worry
about wifi access or sell
data or any of that um engage your brain
with
fun we're done now i just love the cute
little kid they're such cute little guys
they're all so
i'm obsessed with that they're all so
mushy leveling them up i'm just like
i feel like a parent um
i'm like now you're better i don't think
that's what it's like but okay i think
it's a little bit like that
and like when you like put your kid like
in like ballet and then they become like
a great ballerina and you're like you
look i leveled you up
like you could have never done that and
they can never walk again yeah it sounds
like yeah
they're just like a bug engage your
brain with fun puzzles and collect tons
of cute characters
trust me with over a hundred million
downloads wow
this five why do they need us this five
star rated mobile puzzle game
is a must play download best fiends free
on the apple app store or google play
that's friends without the r
best fiends so the first thing i ask on
this show
this is so funny is i ask the guest
if we're friends
the first thing i say is my friend and i
tear up
we are best friends and it's going on 20
years i mean truly 20
years we are so we're so close that this
is actually kind of awkward yeah
we were talking yesterday texting
yesterday we were reminiscing with dory
um are like 30 and um third
third best thirty and uh and i was like
oh remember the first time we saw each
other naked
and now every year it looks a little
different so every time we see each
other naked it's
it's like a new time but so i don't even
know how
to convey how close we are
i mean we met when how old was i 22.
you're 22.
you were forever 22 in my eyes by the
way
but somehow you're aging backwards i was
like what are you eating
no i'm
your driver's license which was expired
which you paid for
i remember when i was like 25 i got in a
car accident and
uh i called our third friend dory at
work and called both of you
you had to come get me and you're like
hey we just need a driver's license and
i was like
and you're like you don't have it right
i was like no and we go down to the dmv
and i had 800 worth of parking tickets
and you guys
paid for it so good we're here why are
you friends with me
and then but and well we were
we were i think when did we all become
ice in each other's phones like
everything there was like
no yeah do you really want to do this
yeah because i remember no because it's
like you've grown
okay so i was okay so we met when i was
probably 22.
i was broke and crazy and the story of
us meeting is nuts
and by the way now i'm just rich and
crazy can i tell that yes please
okay so i
worked with an actor on a movie right
and he's he's one of the only
actors i've ever worked with that i
truly
disdained he was not a good human so of
course i was
dating him but that was the thing so i
he used to talk about this model
that he was if my mom hears this i
better say something else
she will be like he was seeing a model
and he would brag about this often okay
so i was cut to the movie ends and this
this actor is out of my life we never
became friends
and i am at uh the red lobster
on la brea having some garlic cheese
biscuits
and why you were at the red lobster
having some garlic cheese biscuits with
that actor i was anorexic at the time so
i was not having any biscuits
but why were we at red lobster was this
a thing the la brea red lobster in the
what in the early 2000's it must have
been 2005.
so i was with this guy who fully had a
girlfriend
and it was not me oh yeah that i did not
know until later
um who would
i'm i'm trying to i'm who
fully would come on my back and lick it
off
no no no well that's not surprising by
the way
seriously could me too the shit out of
this guy 100 i mean
the things that i went through on that
set that i now recognize
were absolutely we're like sexual
assault and i wouldn't
because i just don't want him in my
google searches
yeah just don't want no and people would
be like who yeah no i want
i mean we will stay silent because we
just want to erase that
yeah just like that period i think i
said a distinct is disdain also a verb
i despise yes anyway i'm disgusted by
yeah he's despicable i'm just picked by
yeah and he apparently just picked all
over your back shit
[Laughter]
who knew wait so when you were in
publicis no you're doing this
the thing is that keeps going through my
mind is my mother and my grandmother but
um
so we so we i was at yes you were seeing
this guy he would brag about you by the
way
while also he had a girlfriend and he
was doing horrible things with an
underage stand-in when we were on
location shooting this
right yes therefore this is my type of
guy
in my early 20s this is what i would
call a dreamboat but apparently a good
choice that he made in life was
seeing you and going to red lobsters i'm
trying to think
how i think i met him at val kilmer's
house well there you go
and um and we were hanging out and he
would always
name drop and try to like impress me
with celebrities and he was like oh
jennifer goodwin and another act yeah
who wasn't famous at the time are at red
lobster and i remember being like
hollywood is so
weird that's weird he came there wait
yes i wouldn't know
okay
a movie but you were in mona lisa smile
by then yes and would it take with daddy
yeah yeah yeah but no but so this was
after the movie i had done with the
despicable
and i was like why are movie stars at
red lobster
since garlic cheese biscuits are really
good so i don't know
so then i wonder if he anyways so you
guys came into red lobster and i
remember he came over and he said
hey do you want it because i was not he
was not there with us
and um and he said hey you want to see
that that
model i'm despicable all over and
i said sure sure i would love to meet
this model that i have heard so
much about so you guys came over and sat
down and i fell
so head over heels in love with you and
i was so confused
and then dory and i were at the like
in style well i remember i met you you
know when you're
in a bad relationship and you meet a
cool girl but but
you're like i'll never be able to be
friends with her because she thinks i'm
like
because you were with them and i was
like oh god she's so awesome but we're
never gonna be able to be friends
because i'm with this like you know um
dude so and then
i remember because you were wearing i
know all of i can literally
name what you were wearing in truly
every story you had this like
like baby blue pea coat with a couple
brooches
from like anthropology sure had a lot of
like anthropology peacoats back then
yeah and brooch is from also
anthropology
so you were wearing that little pea coat
and you were just like so down to earth
and so cool and i was like i want to be
her friend so bad
but she'll never be friends with me
because she thinks that i'm like
associated with this guy
and i'm only with him because i had a
bad childhood i don't like him
well thank god yeah because then we were
at like oh it was like a
oscar party or golden globe this was an
oscar party that i had no business being
at i ended up fumbling into an oscar
party
uh walked in you were wearing white
pants and a black top
and black jibby chew strapping somebody
must have actually dressed me yeah i
don't think so
even i didn't know anything about the
phone you were wearing like white slacks
from like arden b
oh it was like wow oh no then i think
those were mine i probably borrowed the
shoes from dory it was like right before
you got a stylus
yeah it was like all this intervention i
was like is that made well you're going
to move
your side and be like you can't just
shop at goodwill and then come to oscar
parties and i was like i can't
um and i saw you and i like ran up to
you like mama
like i said to dory i was like that
that's her that and so we blatantly
cornered you
and asked you like do you need help
blink twice if you've been kidnapped
yeah like do you want out of that and
into this and
i truly after that we i got your number
mm-hmm
and uh i got you and dory's number and
you're like we should hang out sometime
yeah and you should never hang out with
that guy again yeah
but you should hang out with us and then
uh you know normally when you get
someone's number you're like oh here's
my number and you like maybe text a
month later and kind of just like fade
away
they left and i called you guys
they left and 10 minutes later i caught
it was like okay where are you guys
that's right and that was and the rest
is history that was it
it was like 20 years ago but why did you
why did you
stay friends with me i was so crazy back
then wait not only wait we had to make
you though stay friends with us
do you remember there's been a lot
there's not not in recent years but
there was a lot of
nope you are not allowed to push us away
we are not going anywhere and to the
extent that at your
30th was it your 30th birthday at the
chateau
yes okay that's nuts okay so it was at
your 30s this is
my birthday when um i dragged ginny into
a hotel room and i don't have any
secrets from jenny and it was driving me
so crazy that i had a secret from her
so i dragged her into a hotel room and
took my shirt off and i was like i got
fake boobs
and i was like yes i know because i know
what you i know what you look like in a
t-shirt
oh i thought i was like hiding in front
of you like i have to tell you something
you're like
i know you suddenly green vapes
overnight but
yes but i but the thing is i remember
dory and i were laughing that
we all of these people that we met that
have
come in different you know phases of
your life have come together and and
stuck
you know with you um we were always the
ones to whom they would say oh
you're the old friends and we're like
we're the ones she's had the longest you
don't have to call us
but yeah i'm gonna go with where the
ones she's at i mean the originals the
classic
the vintage friends yeah vintage couture
thank you but yes but i do remember
you've changed my life in so many ways
and anyone that's read
uh my book knows uh ginny
under the fake name of my book jenny
which didn't make me happy when you told
me you were doing that i was like don't
worry i'm changing your name
it's jenny no one will ever love it i
love it you could have put jenny
and uh i didn't even change dory's name
i was just literally just
um and so uh you changed my life in so
many ways and i think you know this i'm
not even sure you know this
do you remember when you and um dory
sent me a chastising email after new
year's
that i i left a new year's eve show
early or uh dinner early to go do stand
up
was this here or was this in new york
this was here and you guys sent me an
email being like
you need to show up more as a friend i
was being really flaky
i was in bad relationships i was like
running around like
cheating and just like i was just a mess
and i was like not putting my
friendships first because
i was so focused on making it as a stand
up remember i would do stand-up like
every night i would
leave dinner i know and you sent me an
email
we went to as many shows as we could
what you went to my first stand-up show
ever
yeah we were scared we were so scared we
were like what i think i mean remember
we tried to have interventions with you
we were
we were like wait you're funny but do
you understand but in like a sad way
people who stand on stage with a
microphone
maybe we should look at other things
when you're a little girl what did you
want to be when you grew up
you knew me before i ever did stand up
oh yeah do you remember when i was like
i'm going to try standing oh yeah no we
were terrified
we're like we think you're funny but uh
we're gonna save you from yourself here
we're usually laughing you because we're
drunk
these these aren't real laughs by the
way we've had like i feel like they've
been you have proved us wrong
but i don't know why you're friends with
us like you've proved us wrong time and
time again
like when you bought your last house
remember dory and i were like should we
talk about
you're buying this big beautiful house
and then you sold three shows like the
next week by the way
and then do you remember we went to a
place called mbar oh yeah
didn't we we even had a birthday party
there would you start out
we made a lot of mistakes with that you
start at the birthday party well no even
whenever ginny and dory uh have
birthdays i
wear a couple weeks apart i have to
insert myself because i feel such fomo
and i feel so left out so we would have
just
like three person birthday parties yeah
i mean like my name would be on the
invite
and your picture sometimes friends
starring whitney
no reason um i did stand up i remember
it it's gonna make me cry actually
if i think about it for too long i went
on stage told a story about dating or
something
and i after i got off i did well my
first set i actually did well
and then i bombed for like years after
that but my first time on stage
no you were yeah normally it's the first
time on stage for people's a disaster
and then they
you know get better and better for some
reason i just got there was some magical
thing that night maybe it's because you
guys were there supporting me or who
knows and my dad was there
and then i came off stage and you
grabbed me and like pulled me to the
ground behind a booth
and we're just like are you me tooing me
right now
[Laughter]
and i felt triggered and unsafe and
ronan farrow i would like to make a
claim
um you grabbed me and you pulled me to
the ground and you were like so giddy
and you were laughing and you were so
like relieved
[Laughter]
like you know when you watch this scary
me watching my kids like do it like i
sobbed through oliver's first
christmas pageant this year because i
he's always been terrified on stage
and that like instills i mean not that
you were terrified but no i mean it's
that's a normal healthy reaction to be
terrified to perform in front of the
people but the fact that i invited
all my friends to my first stand-up show
i mean that could have gone
south and you were so happy for me and i
just
that was the first time in my life i had
really been around women and especially
friends
that were actually happy when i won
you know sometimes people are secretly
rooting for you to fail or really sort
of like to be around people you know
that makes them feel better about
themselves
and i remember you being so happy for me
and that was such a big part of why i
kept going ah
i didn't know that oh
i'm so glad then i've also ruined a
couple of your birthdays was oh
your birthday wait no that was the best
or that
made my birthday wait oh hi that was one
of my favorite birthdays of all time
that was my 30th yeah and do you
remember how i invited you because i was
really proud of myself by the way i
probably tricked no one but i thought i
was being because i'm so
like by the book yes like i'm so i
follow all rules
oh no and i'm bad and for like ginny we
would to go to dinner you'd send me like
a paperless post i'd be like can you
just text me so that's what i did
so i remember what i did was i told you
guys
i sent you guys an invitation and it was
that i said we were going to
a vegas club opening
and that they were going to cover all
travel and that all we had to do was
like xyz with the tabloids and done that
because it was so
not me and the thing is that once you
clicked like this fine print
link i can't believe i haven't figured
out how to do that but
once you click to find print link it was
like actually i'm picking you up in like
a mommy van and we're going to go to
ohio and get
mud baths i was like damn there goes my
husband so we
went to ojai and there was a very small
group of us
and i mean i did get some kind of like i
was in some kind of minivan i had gotten
we got a minivan and jenny is you are
truly
it's so funny because we truly have so
little in common
i mean we are nothing like ginny is like
the most adventurous like
outgoing like she's like okay this
saturday we're going to the rocky horror
picture show
live interactive show like we're going
to this outdoor screening like my
nightmare everything jenny wants to do
involves like bug spray oh you do well
yes you have to like bring lunchables
and like a citronella candle it's like
an excursion
and i remember my husband calls it the
fun army the fun art i want to be like
the the captain of the fun army and i
just like
on a field trip and like a field trip
we're doing things we've got helmets on
we've got like we have to take a class
like to do it
so we're in ohio and i'm like oh we're
just gonna like sit by the pool and like
have margaritas which we also did
we did take a mud bath we did do that
yeah oh that was so fun that was
and uh and jenny's like okay we're gonna
go to an apothecary
and make perfume like that's ginny
goodwin one-on-one i'm just like isn't
there
didn't chanel nail it
same person that i remember remember
like 15 years ago when you're like i got
an ice cream maker
i'm like uh did briars not figure it out
yeah but by the way it also always we
had to get rid of it because everything
just turned into scrambled eggs we made
omelettes we made like chocolate
omelettes yeah because every i can't i
still can't make ice cream i feel like
my cooking skills have someone nailed it
though
ben and jerry nailed it jenny's like no
let me give it a try
and so we go to an apothecary to make
perfume
and i don't remember there's like this
person who's like walking us through it
and we're smelling there's all these
gorgeous glass bottles
all over the wall it's like so magical
there's like you know vanilla
and whatever charcoal and coffee right
and i've invited a bowl to a china shop
i mean within the first 10 minutes i
pick up the
orange blossom one oh yes drop it or
something oh yes
oh yes um so then we tried the teacher
was tried to be
kind and we tried to continue the class
but
everyone everyone could only smell
orange and in fact they decided that we
needed to evacuate
literally the woman was like i have a
migraine i i think we just need to
go for a walk maybe get some air it was
like it was literally just like inhaling
lysol and it was so cute how everyone
was trying to keep going
and she would be like and what does what
do you smell of your like rose amber t
mix and i'd be like orange
i think that's tang i'm pretty sure
that's sun kissed i'm not really sure
but everyone like our eyes were watering
and stuff
that was the best trip we had a picnic
outside
a picnic outside it was the first time i
saw you naked oh was it
i think so i think so no way
probably well maybe i mean whenever we
all started like drawing stuff in the
mud
yeah that's oh yeah because we were in
mud baths yeah it's
interesting i'm such a naked person now
around my friends
and i wasn't back then it was weird i
was like more insecure about my body
back then
yeah but no that's not weird that makes
sense yeah your relationship with your
body has entirely changed
it's so true when ginny knew me let me
ask you a question so
when we first met i had such crazy
eating disorders
did you her face just like the swiss
masks
did you talk about swiss i was like did
you know
candy you knew and cereal i would eat
basically i would go to the grocery
store and i would buy swiss miss hot
chocolate and we would go to like dinner
i can't believe
i cannot believe you guys i would mix it
with water like at a restaurant
yes like eating it like and that's all i
would eat i was also
so broke at the time the fact that you
guys we would go to dinners that i could
not afford because i was so desperate
that was so naive of us too which we
just didn't know but i think
you guys were cool about the fact that i
was like i'll just have a water i'll
just have some of your you know like it
was like i was always trying to manage
it but you guys never made me feel weird
about it you never judge me about it or
i'd say like you know i'm going to come
late
right like i'd come like 10 o'clock and
hang after her that's how you came up
with the idea to start doing comedy
just leave during the during dinner with
you guys
and you won't let me just like scream
about my vagina dinner for two hours so
i should have just been no but we should
have been more considerate more aware of
the fact that we were like going to
these restaurants i should have been
more honest i was a lie
i just would lie because i didn't want
you guys to not want to be friends with
me no god bless
and then so it's so interesting to me
when i have a friend that's going
through something a bad relationship
body stuff eating stuff family stuff and
there's not a ton you can do like
how much did you know about that
it was i mean it was it was 100 obvious
but you and you went to the gym like
twice a day but you guys
never judged me you never no but you
also i also don't think that we
i don't think we can or should nor
should we necessarily want to
change people right like you have to
come to things on your own
but you have to and also you're not
going to love yourself if you don't
and it also doesn't work that's the
other thing no one's ever been in a bad
relationship and i was like hey you know
what you should get out of this and
they're like oh my god good idea well we
all have our shit
all of us have our shit all of us so
it's also i mean that's how i feel about
relationships too like
there's no i mean any kind of
relationship romantic or friendship like
there's always going to be something
there that's like i don't want to say
compromise because i don't think you
should compromise
but there's always going to be something
there that's like the difficult thing
that you navigate
but i don't know i think you kind of
choose like what are those difficult
things that i want to navigate in life
like what am i okay with navigating
instead of it being i don't want yeah i
i would like people to change if they
want to change themselves
i would like to support that process
right but if i try to change you
and you don't it's going to be bad and
if you do now i know you're only this
way because i changed you
well and it's not there like there's
nothing probably lasting about that and
yeah and it's artificial and that
doesn't yeah that's and they like
improve
any kind of like and then you're their
confidence which you now have
because you you went on this journey
like hopefully we held your hands
but you know but you still this was your
journey
i remember because sometimes people just
change your life and they don't even
know they're doing it and i
just it happened at the right time it
was the right person i remember one time
you were at my
apartment back when i lived by the
comedy store and my cabinets were all
full of like
diet soda diet candy diet
crap and i never ate like real food i'm
just called diet
chemicals shit and you open the cabinets
and you just were like
like your face like you were just so
horrified and seeing your face because i
had normalized it it's amazing what we
normalized it's
amazing what we go numb to right and i
remember
going like what was that and you're like
it's just so sad that this is what you
think of yourself
oh and it like i know it was like the
first time you had ever really
acknowledged it and something just like
turned in my brain and i was like got it
like i just got it right away
you said exactly what i need to hear
when i need to hear it the only time i
remember
actively trying to get involved was do
you remember we went and got mani pedis
during some
it was like a an awards show it was like
oscar season or something yes you know
they do all of these for
for listeners who are unaware like we
get spoiled rotten and
you know that we are invited to go to
these you know like how ginny is i'm not
we could this is like people always talk
about celebrities they get like scent
free stuff or whatever
there's these lists where you get scent
free like swag
and ginny will get sent like prada and
like mewmew
i'll get set that all changes as you age
by the way which i've noticed which we
can also talk about at a point
i mean but you get these like gorgeous
like prada like gorgeous loafers
and i will get like slap bracelets in
costco
like dollar store or merch well
i don't think that is the case
necessarily at this point but
we went to it it was like some kind of
award show yeah it was like a pop-up
yeah spa
yes and they said you can come get mani
pedis
and and doesn't it yes and i remember
what i asked you and by the way i am not
like i just got your child for nutrition
but i asked you what did you eat today
yes because you were drinking a
frappuccino yes the sugar-free
sugar-free blended sugar-free ice blend
it was coffee bean i think it was it was
so and and i said can you you i said i
first said
what have you eaten today i was sobbing
crying on my phone
i was in some altercation with some guy
that don't even remember that's how
insignificant it is looking back even
though it felt like the end of the world
i was sobbing crying at this beautiful
suite
and uh i had only eaten basically like
you had a couple of those these like ice
blended they're like frappuccinos
basically that's all i've eaten all day
and i said and
how much did you sleep last night and
you just looked at me and i was like and
he won't text me back
and i don't know what's happening
tonight she just looked at me calmly
this is about yeah what did you eat and
you had not and you hadn't slept the
night before
and i remember i went home and i called
dory and i was like okay
we gotta do something and so what we
tried to do was
trick you into we started looking it
through because also like i mean again
i'm not a poster child for nutrition but
we were like okay so what can we trick
her into thinking is gonna make her
skinnier but it's actually
really really going to like help like
balance her
balance balance balance her because i
remember you guys being like you know
fat actually isn't fattening
sugar actually yeah yes and so the first
thing we did was i sent you an article
about
hydration i remember that and i was like
if you
could drink more water you're going to
be less hungry
i really thought that was an article you
were just setting both of us nope
and then the next one we did was we
started working with you on protein
because we were like if you
eat some protein you won't have to eat
much of
anything else and then it was vegetables
because like if we can get some fiber
you'll poop out all of the food you just
ate and then you won't gain any weight
and like it was like
that was the only time i felt like we
got we did try to be
manipulative because we were like if we
can just make her sing
that we're aiding in a bedding
it's just called and then
maybe because we were like if she's
hydrated we think and i
also i mean i don't drink much why drink
crystal late like crazy yeah
but um but yeah so that was that i feel
like that was the only time we tried to
actively interfere
and how are you so like i mean since
i've known you you've always had such a
clear take on relationships you've given
me some of the best advice i've ever
gotten in relationships
this truly blew my mind seriously no i
know you've been in some doozies
i was
oh i'm aware
you had to watch me have crazy eating
stuff i had to watch you in some crazy
relationships
god i'm sorry with some of the guys
you'll have to put up with no
it's i'm so gl i love i love
i love your past because it makes your
current relationship
that much more magical oh sure you know
what i mean because i feel like had we
not made all those mistakes and gone
down all those weird paths we wouldn't
be having to compare
yes no i wouldn't say i think i take
pride in i do think i'm a person who
says oh that didn't work i'm gonna try
this other thing yes you're so good at
that
and not taking it personally and not
overthinking it yeah that was that
moving on i also am just
particularly thrilled that the man you
did marry uh is
my soul mate oh absolutely i know we are
like
we are the same person i'm basically
married i mean
truly i've married like the first time i
met josh we were like in a corner like
dying laughing and like had so many
inside jokes within five oh yes
sometimes i'll even be like who are you
texting and flirting he's like it's
widow okay yeah yeah yeah
you're her husband and i are like truly
this like past life twins or something
so sometimes i come to you and i'm like
hey i don't understand i know what is he
doing up like oh that's what he's doing
yeah i'll text him i got it yeah you've
given me all these things
yeah i'm so obsessed but you said some
things that changed my life because
for the longest time in relationships
the only power i thought i had was
withholding or leaving well and one time
you said
leaving is not an option do you remember
that yeah
i got that from someone else who
probably doesn't want to be name checked
but that that blew my mind when someone
said that to me a long time and i was
like oh no but going i'm leaving was
what i
the leverage that i thought that i had
absolutely and you're like no you just
stay in the ring
everything if you think i'm staying in
the ring
you actually open up you actually like
try to negotiate
something with someone and you how did
you know
josh was like it i mean i know why
but it's like we've been in love a lot
and we've been i've known you through a
lot of relationships where i've thought
i've met the one i thought i found out
i was in london where we both were like
okay i've said to you this is the one oh
yeah
many times yeah you've said it to me
many times yeah and i do think there are
many the ones by the way like i think
that i don't believe there's just one
person for us i think
so many elements of course plan to it
like just timing yeah like time and
place
where you are and you're my other
soulmates are just too far away right
like
i mean i do believe when people say like
oh if only i'd met you sooner or things
like that like well that's probably true
yeah like if you admit timing is
everything and experience the experience
that you have leading up to something
and i i met josh i was engaged to be
married of course
and yeah right and um i met josh and
i and what i thought was i am in trouble
because
i did think that there was not
i don't think i think josh will love
this and not hate that i'm saying this
um
listen to this never he's a um
not a fan right but you asked me and i'm
like what's a podcast because like that
thing i'm always listening to that
does um so so i had always thought
that i needed to either be in a
relationship where i was in lust or i
was in love
but i had never had both i just hadn't
and it didn't occur to me there could be
both
and i was engaged to the most wonderful
man um but there were just things that i
didn't have in that relationship that i
met josh and i thought but here's the
thing
i thought i would not end up with josh
because also his dance card was full at
the time
but i thought now i know that i could
end up with someone like josh
mm-hmm so what i don't they exist
they're out there
hold out for a hero absolutely so i met
him
called my mother and i was on location
for once upon a time and i said
i'm in trouble and she said you don't
i'm in trouble i met whitney's songs
i met whitney as a man and um and i will
never forget my mother putting it this
way and by the way she didn't have time
to think this up this was a one phone
call
like revealed to her i said i met this
man
this is how i feel and now i know and my
mom said that you need to cancel the
wedding and i said yes and she goes
baby canceling a wedding is hard but
it's not that hard
and there was something about that that
took
like i cannot describe the relief i felt
now also i am a spoiled brat i mean my
wedding by the way was
bought and paid for and i didn't realize
that i had kept the invitations it was a
remember it was
it was a destination wedding we were at
knoxville or nashville we were going to
be in memphis that's right
but i had not ever actually sent out the
invitations
i had never actually opened the box and
it hadn't occurred to me that
that was weird that they were just
sitting in my garage
like four months before the wedding and
that i still had not
and also had not told my fiance that i
had not taken care of even opening the
box and looking at the invitations
so when my mother said that and i
realized i just needed someone to give
me permission
and to tell me like i like i feel like a
million mothers on this planet would
in doing the right thing by their
children to say don't cancel this on a
whim let's just see this through like
my mother just knew and she knew that
there were so many elements that were
keeping me like entrapped in this thing
and that the wedding was probably the
biggest one of
the biggest elements yes the logistics
and so not only
did that happen but then i called my
dreamy father-like
business manager that i've had for 20
some odd years stuart i'm going to make
sure you right now listen to this it's
just paying her nothing
sorry i had people really taking care of
me during that time
and again did not think i was going to
end up with josh but
realized that's what i want i want
someone just like that who gives me
these feelings yeah
and who is such a friend and who he was
just the whole package
so we and then his dancer besides the
fact that he's
butt ugly right obviously i mean he's
just like he's just kind of ugly that's
the only major
you know my problem just like ugly bad
just gross body so
he ended up so his dance court card went
it
when it freed up we still decided that
we were just going to be friends because
then we were trying to be terribly
responsible adults and we were saying
okay but we're on a show
and if we i mean inevitably this will
end and i'm snow white and you're prince
charming and it makes no sense yeah it
makes
it makes no sense that would be together
and there's no cliches there's no
metaphors like god's not trying to tell
us anything the universe is not aligning
in our favor like nothing
but we but what if it that we were sure
because also we are actors and we are on
a set and we are on location and we are
sure that this is a bubble thing and
this is not gonna work and we're gonna
ruin this for everybody and what we came
down to
too was and then one of us is going to
have to leave the show and it's not
going to be me
so are you ready to be unemployed
because prince charming is going to have
to disney's going to have to appreciate
your mom
being killed yeah um because you're not
staying when we break up because we're
not going to make everybody miserable so
we tried until like the fall to
stay friends and people don't believe us
by the way i don't
believe that i believe you because i
remember having to fucking hear about it
and us being like just what is this like
sit outside your house i was smoking i
was like what is this performance where
we're pretending you're not going to be
together
it's just like we got together in the
fall and on our first date we were like
all right
we're going to take the slow and then we
moved in
10 minutes later and then we went to the
show and we're like hey
we're gonna get i know remember i
remember when you were like ah we're
like not gonna get married we're just
gonna like
oh i tried to not get married for so
long and do you remember that so i was
because josh kept saying things about
you know he very gallantly wanted to
wanted to wed yeah um and i would always
say no offense it's not you
it's me but i really feel like you know
i don't really understand what marriage
marriage doesn't mean the thing that it
should mean for us to get married
it's you know i was just on that one
here needs citizenship what are we doing
like we just didn't i didn't feel like
we needed the piece of paper i was like
can't we just be together forever
yeah um i've already canceled one
wedding yeah and he had been married and
so i kept saying no and then something
i mean i'm sure it was biological but
thank god when i was
i mean because we did plan on let's live
together and have babies the babies were
very very much planned
and um i remember like the day that this
switch
flipped and i came home and i was so
pregnant
it's when you were yep and i was like i
want your name
i want your health insurance i know i
have my own but i want you you are your
dna i want it all fancy ring that is way
too expensive
like the whole kitten caboodle and he
was very generously
you know inclined to oblige so he
patient with
ammunition turning into the marriage so
yeah
you were maybe eight months eight months
pregnant yeah
and what made you decide to do it
pregnant i suddenly
wanted i mean that did become a
logistics thing where i was like i want
to ha
i want this baby to come in the i want
us all to have the same name
and i remember right during the wedding
right i
realized what marriage does mean to me
tell me by the way
i was too busy
to anybody other than my husband um when
i was growing up
i thought that my parents were related
because i i mean it's just like my son's
proposed to me
all the time by the way i always say yes
do you blame him yeah
i don't know what kind of messing up i'm
doing hugo asked me the other night he
was like because
we let them crawl in bed with us in the
middle of the night and the other night
he asked me
if he could still sleep on the same side
of the bed when he's a grown-up
and i was like absolutely and josh that
there will be more room because i'll be
at my girlfriend's house
my house it'll be i'll be at women we'll
be here i said we'll miss you
but um but just like my children are
always proposing to me um and i really
do hope we get married
um is so cute oh my god it's so good by
the way
maybe they watched big love a couple
times oliver said to us the other day
he said daddy i'm gonna marry hugo and i
could punch
i could punch josh because his reaction
was buddy that's not really legal
and i want i wanted to be like no great
well i will plan the reception now we
just have to stay together
but i've got lots of invitations i'm
just crossing out names
but um but but i thought my parents were
related
because i didn't understand i don't know
there was just no concept
they were family so how were they not
like blood relation
and during the wedding i suddenly i
remembered it
during the wedding that that's what i
thought of my parents and i realized i
felt that way about josh
like that we were somehow that this that
this formality
and making us family was making us like
have this
like truly inseparable like blood tie
and because he's been married before i
did tell him by the way at the wedding
during the ceremony i leaned over and i
said
you realize that if you did this again
it'd be real tacky
so you are so stuck with me like like
i just like leaving
it's not just about child support this
is you cannot like
like you cannot leave and i do i did
realize
too that like save for either i've had
so many relationship deal breakers in my
life
and but i realized with josh this is so
terrible because it sounds like i'm
giving him like some kind of pass but
even if he murdered somebody i think i'd
still be like
pretty good like as long as we're
together we're together like when i had
oliver the first thing that went through
my head
was oh i understand like if you like all
the women that i like watch interviewed
on the news like
if you ever did anything like i would
hide you and lie to everyone about where
i would protect you from from from
everyone
like crazy love that documentaries are
made about yeah yeah
yeah this is here just i feel like this
is now evidence of you in the basement
and i would lie to everyone
so that they couldn't find you like i
suddenly got that
like my camera yes primordial
ferocious love at all costs which is why
i do think that like my career has
and all my dreams have entirely changed
because which i had to go through
mourning about for sure
i thought you were going to say had been
shattered but i'm glad you said no no no
no it's a choice i hope i mean aging in
hollywood is one thing but
i but no i i realized i always thought
that my kids were going to come along on
the ride with me
because come on like getting to be a
working actress it's a
it's a wild ride it is as
i mean it's a it's a crazy roller
coaster but it's
really exhilarating and i thought that
my kids would just come with me on the
ride
and the second i had them i was like oh
no you are the ride
you are the ride and i am i don't know
i'm like your escort at the theme park
who's gonna like
you know protect you and hold your shit
i remember when
you for it was so hard for me to
understand when you got famous because
it was like i met you
before you got like famous famous and
then you got famous but
you were just ginny's yeah it was just
like that always gets so confusing
and then because i remember being like
we were your plus one for all of your um
uh the walk the line remember the walk
the line
you're more than my plus one for a while
well for walk mine first of all
i remember you went to did you shoot in
tennessee right yeah in memphis and you
came back
and uh we went and picked you up from
the airport and we're like
jenny why did the studio not send me a
car by the way
it's taken me like 20 years to say why
he's like i'm landing from shooting this
movie with reese witherspoon and joaquin
phoenix at lax like
tonight at eight o'clock or something
any way you can there is supposed to be
a car
there is supposed to be a transportation
i don't know how my agents missed this
the fact that we were picking you up is
already weird and we were like oh she's
gonna have changed she just
this big studio movie she's gonna come
back she's gonna be such an asshole
like the jenny we'd love is gonna be
just like this diva she gets in the car
and that fucking picot the same fucking
blue nasty
coat same price and she's like i'm
starving is there a taco bell close by i
needed a mexican pizza and a sport
like nobody's business the same bitch
she's the same
pitch she's always been still love taco
bell i remember back then
and by the way it's not like there was a
taco bell in memphis yeah i don't know
you had just had it in the airport
probably
no way i had another did you ever feel
weird
about your body
[Laughter]
she says she adjusts her body shape i
just mean i remember like
i just remember there being so many
weird little like
things about that and when you i feel
like things have changed in the last
couple years a little bit you can tell
me if i'm wrong
no i'll talk openly but i feel like when
we started it was like
women's thighs couldn't touch oh my gosh
you know who
really uh had a huge impact on me was
julia roberts like
and i did my first movie with her so
wild i know and she
i feel like she took me under her wing
in a way that i mean i've i i oh i owe
her so much we all do
yeah we all know we all owe her um
when i started i had never by the way i
was on weight watchers as a child so i
had
but i guess i had body issues because
i felt really because of weight watchers
i think i i felt really
good about just being who i was and
being healthy and
and i don't know even though i read a
lot of fashion magazines
i never thought i was supposed to i
don't know i never
i never thought like my thighs weren't
supposed to touch yeah um i just thought
like i
like this is this is the me package and
i am an actress and i am stunning and
gorgeous
and i'm nailing it but i was shocked
when we started doing
press from mona lisa smile i mean i was
supposed to be like
my character in mona lisa smile was
supposed to be uh mousy
right a little dowdy but that's really
fun and you know
i like not having to put on as much
makeup like it's like like i don't know
i don't consider that like
an insult yeah in any way but um
but i remember when the press started
coming out because you could never look
down but yeah
that's true that's stunning by the way i
dressed up today because i was i put on
a sweatshirt this morning like no this
is
gonna look like i rolled out of bed um
but i
i remember when the press came out and
when i would do interviews
i mean people were really mean and i
remember
the girls but of mona lisa smile all
i mean seriously like especially like
you know um well
they all got my back but especially
julia roberts got my back
and we would all get very defensive like
they'd ask you questions and junkets
yeah like i was in a huge press
conference and i actually had a
journalist say what's it like to be
like you know uh like a heavy actress in
hollywood
and the thing that's not i mean i
exploded i lost my mind on this woman
and i did have my publicist at the time
called me aside after aft it was a woman
of course it was a woman wow
um and then i did have my publicist pull
me aside afterwards and say here's the
problem with how you handled that
your reaction is all that they will now
print they don't
show they're not going to show this
woman there's no camera on this woman
yes they're not gonna you have got to
learn how to and she taught me that the
art of
um i love this is like a zootopia thing
by the way like totally plugging
zootopia
i think everyone's seen it so there's
this little movie i did
but um but that you know you if you
don't want to answer the question that
they ask answer a different question
because the questioner is not going to
ever be on camera
um so anyways my what's it like to be so
gorgeous oh thank you so much for asking
oh my gosh oh my god i'm flustered but
instead i really was an asshole to this
woman like she deserved it but i
attacked her her physically and things
like that so
um that was not cool but i feel like
julia did a really good job of both
um protecting me and saying things like
taking microphones and saying jenny's
not gonna answer that
especially two about personal things
like if anybody asked me about men
she would say jenny's not gonna answer
that and not in a controlling way and
truly like
she was my buddy through all of this i
think we forget i especially think in
this business when you're like oh i'm
hired to do
to be a puppet and to do what other
people say i just have to give and give
and give myself away and she kept
i remember i'll never forget like she
cornered me after we did a photo shoot
together because there were
also she would refuse to do photo shoots
without me for press
like when i wouldn't be asked to be part
of a magazine spread she'd be like not
only am i not doing this
without jenny but she's going to be the
one on the page with me things like that
and i remember she also cornered me we
read a shoot and she said
please please please please don't ever
get it give in to this body image shit
like you are beautiful do not change
please do not let go
like do not listen i'm sorry size four
like i was probably like a four six
yeah like i was probably like a good six
but like
that's tiny like now i'm like like truly
i would give to you i couldn't i
remember i couldn't fit into your
ginny had one marc jacobs dress that she
wore for about four years
but everyone would wear the dress and
then i went to put a dominate i couldn't
even fit it up my back
no and i remember because you're just
built differently because you've always
been slimmer than me for sure but we
have
it doesn't yeah the point is i think
what comes off on camera
it's like if someone's face is more
round or more you know but that's the
thing i've never been like i'm like
like and people always meet you and
they're going she's tiny
and p and i've always taken that too as
i mean it's a compliment but it is
a testament to you yes movie star on a
giant screen
it was a crazy road in the beginning
but i would say my body so i would say
i've never had issues
except this i would like
there to be more attention paid to what
happens to the female body during
pregnancy and afterwards
because i feel like i read everything
and i watched everything and i feel like
there is this
there's so much put on to pregnancy and
postpartum life that's like trying to
convince ourselves of this thing
as in i thought that pregnancy was gonna
be all like
you know rainbows and unicorns and that
i was gonna
you know love being pregnant and love
have you know like
love the delivery people yeah yeah yeah
and that postpartum life would be about
like bonding with my baby
and it was truly friends who said to me
by the way
you probably haven't read this in any of
the like 400 books you've read but like
you're gonna be in a diaper and your
belly's
not gonna go back no matter how much you
exercise
and your skin and your stretch marks and
the sags and that shit will
never go away no matter how hard you
were i mean like i have a friend who
um will remain nameless who had ruined
her couch
because she was breastfeeding her child
and had a hemorrhoid and it exploded oh
yeah
bright red blood bleeding i remember and
by the way
so this is the story of can we do this
on your show yeah
okay so i was um having like
the same issues all pregnant women have
where like i you know which i'll
suddenly be like i'm bleeding all over
the floor like after i had the baby
um or i was wetting my pants endlessly
for months
and um but anyways in the beginning when
i was wetting my pants i didn't want my
husband to know by the way he delivered
the baby like i got a wet ass pussy
i'm just squirting you made me wet you
make me so well i don't know why i
thought he would find this unattractive
he delivered the babies and still wants
to have sex with me
but i was still like hiding these things
from him because i thought they were
so not like feminine and attractive like
a crevice is a crevice
so i was calling i remember calling mine
i went into the bathroom and as if
having the bathroom door
closed was not enough and as if he
wasn't like downstairs i remember hiding
i like crouched down by my own toilet
to get on the phone with my ob gyn and i
called him and i was whispering
and i was like i'm wetting my face
and i'll never forget this he goes yep
and i was like
[Laughter]
i'm wet like i will get up and realize i
like wet
the seat that i was sitting on and i
didn't know it and yep
and i was like okay so wait what are you
not understanding like i am
like a child like i i can't stop wetting
my pants and he goes
you had a baby what did you expect
by the way love that about stuff they
don't prepare you for yeah
and so and then i found out but that was
actually when i found out that i needed
to actually order and wear diapers but
um
but i feel like there's something that
hap like
i see a disconnect there's a lot of like
love your body love your body love who
you are
but i don't see a lot of like
love the like saggy belly you're now
gonna have for the rest of your life but
i also would like to have been prepared
for it
yes i mean there was so much stuff i
remember when both you and dory
um uh had babies i remember dory saying
i thought everyone's water broke right
as we see in movies like splash time to
go to the hospital
she's like i felt contractions but i was
like oh there's no like weed
where is the information to actually
prepare people i feel like
this step-by-step romantic comedies in
the 80s are most of our preparation for
yeah but no it took me getting like a
phone call from a girlfriend in england
who was like oh by the way when you're
in the hospital
ask them for the numbing spray and i'll
tell everybody this i'm like
you after you have a baby i'm going to
tell you this right now after you have a
baby
after my surgery yeah baby so so you
want to tell the surrogate
to um you get this like because they
don't just give it to you have to get
your doctor to get a prescription for it
but it's like this
sport like injury numbing spray and you
use that down there
also like you can't like sit on a toilet
or wipe for a eon so i started using a
hair dryer at the
toilet to like prevent like getting
rashes and things i have a friend who
tore
12 inches oh yeah and she had to go get
the
rejuvenation oh yeah and she said that
was more painful than the childbirth
really yeah i'm not gonna lie when
during my second child at my doctor
because the second one like falls out
and um and so after hugo like fell out
into josh's arms
i looked at the doctor and i was like
hey while you're down there
well there are some things that i and he
was like i feel like people
remember too the doctor said i feel like
we've accomplished a lot here today
i can't feel anything anyway i didn't
you don't even need to put me under i
did say to him by the way which i do
appreciate and this is about like love
your body stuff i did say to him like is
there any way that i can get like a
tummy tuck and have
um like at the same time that i knock it
out two birds yeah like
but i bet i was having my babies
vaginally and he was like nope and i was
like
this is hollywood i'm sure that there's
a come on there's gotta be a guy and he
walked me through
why you know if you decide to do this
down the line
that's one thing but this is why i'm not
going to let you go through like that
process while you're going through this
process right which i really appreciate
you're gonna be breastfeeding you're
gonna be on painkillers and
he was like and it's messy and you're
just getting somebody who can i mean he
had all kinds of
good reasons for like you know science
and body and healing and things
they um she said that when she went and
got the vaginal rejuvenation the doctor
asked her
size wise would you like to go back to
16 18 or 21. and i was like
no how big of a difference
was your i was like that is so sp my
vagina did not change size
between 16 and 18. i don't think that's
amazing what did she decide by the way i
think she went back to like 18. yeah
but she was just like yeah she was like
18 and 16. it was like such a specific
projection by the doctor right it was
just like where did you get these
numbers
um but yeah you can like decide how
small you want it to be
we gotta do it two for one at some point
how um did you
get so clear on
you've always been so relentlessly
authentic i know it's your mom i know
your mom i have so
she's i know she's a superhero and she's
a saint like why have you always been so
authentic like you never lie you've
never been fake
i'd probably be a terrible liar let's
just be honest i mean
she's for for a literally one of the
most brilliant actresses working today
she's a horrible liar gives me the
hardest time about we'll see someone
like at a restaurant free pandemic show
like wow you hate that person i'm like
no i wasn't supposed to you could tell
could you just act the way you do in
movies
without the camera no idea you were that
bad an actress in real life
but it's just like there's no there's
never any drama with you
there's never any like i feel like i'm
so spoiled by my relationship
with you and our third dory because then
afterwards i'd work with people and i'm
like oh people are uh
people are nuts people are nuts you know
what is it is it
being from tennessee is it your mom i
think
i don't think well by the way and i've
never talked about this before on camera
i'm recording with anyone i mean you've
heard this
so when i mean i think that a lot of who
i am
i mean is obvi is like just really
really really good
i hope parenting and grandparenting and
having a superhero sister as well too my
experience
and your grandmother collected dolls
what could have gone wrong
one of the biggest collections in the
world um i've got a doll i've got a
porcelain doll myself
um but um but uh
you know when i was a teenager i was in
a really abusive relationship
and i was and i suffered from depression
and
saw doctors for years and years and
years and by the way those
one did not lead to the other it was
just like the perfect storm of
adolescence
um and being in a bad situation and you
know my parents tried to keep me out of
the abusive relationship and to help me
and they did they they took every step
that a parent should take to help a
child in that situation
meaning like they were you know the safe
place for me to go
um and they got me the help that i
needed and made me see that asking for
help is the absolute categorical most
noble thing that you could ever do
um there's some like they really made me
see that like there is strength
in saying i can't do this by myself and
and so i do feel like i i think that
there was a f like a moment when i was
about 16
when i realized that my life could
really go one of several different ways
and that
most of the ways were were a very very
bad way
um and i could make a choice and i just
suddenly
for me for me how i've navigated how i
navigated mostly in the past
because it was a chemical thing that
that seems to have righted itself as i
have
you know as my hormones have bounced out
um
so it was okay i need to go on
medication and i need to talk to people
regularly
and and get that help that my parents
taught me i need a bit like the choice
is going to be
to change my life like i can i can
i think i felt like there was nothing to
lose
right can't get worse like it was i was
in such a bad dark place that i was like
well i could just keep going down
those like several different roads that
i can envision or
i could choose the like really really
really unlikely
road which is i leave memphis and i try
to get into the top acting schools
and i you know never come home again
except to see my family
and i just go to a movie with julia ross
right and i just maybe i should do that
just like try to do the other thing like
try to do the opposite of what i'm doing
now
contrary action and see if that was that
what that's called and i was like and we
can just like it's not like
failing would matter because i can
always do that later
yes i can always go back to that yeah
but like i haven't
tried the thing that is i haven't tried
the unlikely thing that is like what if
i could
become a working actress and support
myself doing that and
have a different life and surround
myself with a different kind of people
and and so when that
so but also i'm i'm spoiled rotten in
that it worked so quickly like there was
such immediate gratification like i got
into the top acting schools
um but i think also because i was just
being super nervy um
because i had nothing to lose and i
remember going up to like the you know
head of the
program at the school that i chose um
and said i think my audition was
terrible and i said i can't wait to see
you in the fall
and i think that it was that kind of
thing i did that at my first movie
audition for
mona lisa smile that was my first movie
audition and i said the same thing to
the director i like got 1950s clothes
and went to the audition and said
like i can't wait to see what's said
because which is really me being an
asshole
it's so i don't recommend people so
crazy now that you would like yeah if
you hadn't gotten the job it would have
been insane oh by the way like now
also that i like screen test people on
the other side
like helping people get some job i'm on
like i'd be so turned off by someone
saying that to me i think
i also remember when you auditioned for
big love you went in
and you were thrown like you just lost
focus oh yeah you said can i go outside
and collect myself and collect myself
and listen to my yeah my music music for
a second and come back
yeah and i thought i had ruined it you
took control of your environment
but i thought that i was like oh i
wasted all their time i probably ruined
it but it was the only way that i could
yeah
get myself where i needed to be to then
go back in and then how did you know you
were just like i'm not
i need to just like regroup like how did
you know to
take that contrary action really like
when you have 10 people staring at you
like tom hanks and brilliant writers
you know what i'm really good at which
josh and i have had to learn to
um navigate because he's not like this
um
no he's like me i'm like i would rather
just fail in front of you then take five
minutes for myself
and if we have a conflict like josh
wants to address it head on
and i am hardcore about i need to walk
away from this
and i'll be back i love you i am not
abandoning you what have you eaten today
yes
but i'm not gonna i'm not gonna address
this
until i st i have to i'm a step away yes
uh
that's what we use we're all working
towards uh the ability to take
pause yes to go you know what pause i'm
gonna go for a walk i'm gonna collect
myself because right now i'm gonna say
something cruel
i gotta say something mean i'm gonna
regret it i'm gonna roll my eyes yep and
it's not gonna be how i feel
yes i'm gonna regret it say what you
mean mean what you say and don't say it
mean i am not there yet
let me just circle back yeah so i'm
hardcore i mean i
any fight starts and i'm like i'll be
back like don't don't i'm
i'm not abandoning this i'm not
abandoning you but i'm walking away yeah
adults can be abandoned
oh that's we have cars yeah my therapist
our therapist says that all the time
because i'm like i just feel abandoned
by this person and she goes adults can't
be abandoned that's
you have a car you have a house thanks
only children can be abandoned
so that's a killer no i'm going to use
this you don't get to have that yeah so
i'm big on call georgia with everyone in
my life by the way because at this point
i've sent everyone
i've had george on the podcast everyone
knows everybody everyone knows right now
i sent george's podca that podca i sent
that around to people who i've been
who have been saying like i really think
i need someone i'm like you need georgia
yeah everyone yep yep yep
we'll have josh and i will have
discussions about you know something
regarding because
i do feel like i take gross advantage of
georgia because i'm always like how do i
not mess up my our kids like i'll call
and be like can they watch star wars
what do you do with that by the way this
this therapist has star wars posters in
her office
can they watch game of thrones um what's
been the most surprising
feedback you've gotten from her in terms
of something you thought was going to
mess a kid up but doesn't
oh my gosh i mean she's like i feel like
she has absolutely
like created the structure that is our
child rearing
um and that's and like here's the thing
i feel like my childhood was spectacular
i am like obsessed with josh's mother
who's like the healthiest most brilliant
like i
won the mother-in-law oh my god i love
her so much she is so
she's everything you want in a mom
she's just like i won the mother-in-law
contest i get so
if she's gonna come visit and josh is
out of town like who would play her
more time catherine keener laura dern
oh laura
the best energy like an amazing big
heart beautiful
blonde so smart just like so like she'll
just she'll say things to me that i'm
always like how did you know how to
handle yes she's just like elegant but
like
wears more turquoise jewelry than me and
she's
always making she's you can hear her
coming i like the dangling
worst shit um i get so stoked yesterday
i was on the i was on facetime with her
for so long before i was like i better
show
josh i'm talking to you i'm going to get
in trouble i'm going to be like why have
you not
just pure wisdom so so
it's not that we are reacting to that
and i just want to like disclaimer and
going to georgia but we but because
we're actors we really went to where we
were like how do we not mess them up
more
yeah um and she's so how do we act like
we're good parents
right right and she's been i mean her
whole thing
is structure and routine and boundaries
and all these things that are very also
like
it worked this works very well for me um
so i feel like the the thing that
actually surprised me the most was
it just involved this logistical thing
that was we were going to be
josh and i had to move and move and move
during a very short period
um while we were shooting some specific
things for once upon a time
she told us to leave our kids at home
and i was like i thought it's sort of
like that i thought they were going to
come along with me for the ride thing
and even though we were already there it
put it in i don't know it put
even clarified you know that like
shifted things even more into focus
she was like no no you're not going to
drag them from
location to location location for these
months your mother is
staying at your house they have an
opportunity to be in school
so as long as they are getting eye
contact and attention and love and feel
safe
all of these things they get from your
mother as it is so
and your mom's raring to go and that is
how we're designed we're designed to be
raised by a couple different women the
village it doesn't only have to be the
mom yeah
and she was like so they stay in la with
your mother
you facetime them all the time you keep
technology away from them otherwise but
you spend time with them
non-stop and like you like they will be
so happy and they they don't care at all
when they know that josh is going away
for six months
they have this thing that they say back
and forth with josh where they go they
say daddy comes back
always always always and the thing that
i think is different about
oh like families that are separated like
truly separated
or families of the past who didn't have
face time technology is
they probably did feel a sense of
abandonment but and josh fears that with
our kids but georgia keeps telling us no
because the thing is when he's gone to
new york to shoot manifest for
six months a year my kids are being told
incessantly by me that their father
adores them that he misses them i mean
we
give them you know dad sends them
millions of presents and he facetimes
him non-stop and they wear t-shirts with
his face on it and they sleep on pillows
with his face on it and like
they don't feel it's harder on us than
it is on that yeah
for them it's normal but not the kind of
normal that is like abandonment is
normal
they for them it's just you know daddy's
still coming they focus on the come back
part
yeah they can and they can adapt more
than we can like you know and i remember
she was telling me once like
us worrying about kids is so much harder
on them
than the thing we're worrying about
because they just see us worrying and
panicking yes but they don't know what
we're worrying about so they're just
like all right
they feel the worry they're just
learning stress and they're just
learning panic although oh yeah
they something else that georgia says
that i love that i throw at people is um
she says you know like life is the ocean
and the parents are the buoys
oh so we try to always be the buoys
always and we try to never
undermine each other so what do you do
so you
do you say okay uh one of the kids wants
a chocolate bar or whatever he asked us
we have to go agree and then come back
with one answer
no but we don't counter what the other
parent has decided
if and if there's a conversation that
needs to be had about dude
the sugar then we have that you have to
be a united front
yes but we'll make that decision
afterwards we can't do because we're
also realizing we can change the rules
on the kids
yeah yes yes yes but you can't disagree
in front of them no
so negotiate with terrorists because if
daddy says something that's amazing if
daddy says something i do go with it
even if i hate it and then i'll have a
private conversation with josh
because what i don't want is my kids to
think that i don't want them
i don't want them to see me undermining
their dad ooh
something my children will see all day
right now their dad needs to their dad
is like
he's the king of the house and he needs
to be empowered and i'm the queen of the
house and i need to be to be in power
this is why jenny will be married
forever
i will be single
are forever googling a french word what
are you on your own
are you googling a french word ready you
are
new foreign nope okay i don't know
mine fell out new foreign
means now for a break in swedish
oh i say shut up talking to me in
swedish hal
kauftin i like that that's not serious
that's shut up in swedish hall
coughton the point is the point is you
need to be able to insult people in
every language
yeah that's what i'm trying to say here
you need to be able to fight in every
language you need to be able to gossip
about people and other languages so they
can't understand you
um smorgasbord
i can say tocara de la fante muy
offended what does that mean your
elephant face offends me
i had one of my managers was puerto
rican and she only taught me things like
that she's like do you wanna know how to
say anything helpful and i was like
no you're not babble just teach me the
insults brah
just so you know this is an ad for
babble we have an institute that means
good
bra well here's the thing i matched with
a guy from stockholm on a dating app so
he said yeah bro take off your bra
he said bra bra so i know
bro so now i need to learn a language
immediately um
and i've tried before like i i feel like
i learned some french in high school but
i didn't really stick
i wasn't paying attention i wasn't
focused i didn't really um
i don't do well in like 45 minutes at a
time teaching chunks i just like it
doesn't work for me
i get bored but babel figured it out
how they're 10 to 15 minutes they
figured out a way to teach you a
language
that you can actually absorb it you can
actually remember it and
works with my attention and they teach
you words and phrases in like sentences
and not like here's how you say scarf
and you're like and and
what context in what context you're just
like la bufanda
de brah me fully talking about other
languages when i can barely speak
english
talk what that means thank you thank you
swedish
they even have a dog what i like about
this because you know i have a wild ass
voice
is that this has speech recognition
technology so it helps improve your
pronuncia
that word your pronunciation fact that
you can't pronounce the word
pronunciation your pronunciation
and accent and i was like i need that
garnet uh they have 14 different
languages including spanish french
italian and german that you can choose
from that
our clock clan that means what time is
that
vadar clock clan what time is it
that it's time that our clock and clock
and
top battle's like this is not what we do
they're like go to the app download the
app 14 different languages spanish
french italian and german i love to
learn german
babel is available in an app or online i
do it on an app when i'm working out
am i allowed to say i like to sync it
across all devices and you can do it
really yeah you can also do when you're
like going for a walk when you're
working out when you're running like i
learn better when i'm like moving um
right now if you purchase a three-month
subscription babble we'll give our
listeners three additional months
free wow with promo code good for you
three additional months free if you go
to babel.com learn that language today
now's the time we're in a pandemic
we're gonna be able to travel soon soon
the borders are gonna open up and you're
going to want to travel you're going to
want to go to europe you're going to
want to go to germany you want to go to
france or spain because life is short
because we're living in a nightmare
you're going to want to go to italy
so you need to learn the language first
don't be disrespectful
babble three additional months free if
you go to babel.com
use promo code good for you brah
on your three-month subscription
babble.com
that's b-a-b-b-e-l.com
promo code good for you broad job
ah better help better help me read this
ass
um
please leave that in
go please listen there's something
interfering with your happiness
no comment or preventing you from
achieving your goals
your goals right here
right here better help can access
your needs to match you with a lo what
better help will help you find a life
and professional therapist
you can start communicating 48 hours
speak from the heart
i need help better health this is a cry
for health
i need better help because they can
connect me to a licensed professional
therapist i can talk to them
real quick um i can do it from the
comfort of my home
you guys can do it you can't not be in
therapy you have better help
has made it so there's no excuse anymore
to be crazy yeah what therapist can you
eat nuggets and talk to
when can i eat a bowl of teddy grahams
while also crying on my couch that is so
royal i didn't even think about that you
better help you can
snack while healing your childhood you
really can well i think
i it took me so long to get into therapy
because number one i couldn't afford it
but number two the driving there the
parking the rigmarole
the it's just like and then you're
worried you're gonna run into someone in
the waiting room like it's just such
a not therapeutic experience going to
therapy
betterhelp does it in the privacy of
your own home you can log in anytime
send a message to your counselor you're
gonna get timely responses
write that in there so that you don't
take an action or send that email or say
that thing you can never do also
therapy is a luxury and better help is
more affordable that's right and they
also offer financial aid
yes but you save money in the long run
for not having to pay for that divorce
yeah
that too better help wants you to start
living a happier life today
you deserve it visit their website read
their testimonials
that are posted daily it's more
affordable than traditional offline
counseling visit betterhelp.com whitney
you do the rest benton this is where you
shine
visit betterhelp.com whitney that's
betterhelp help
and join the over one million people
taking charge of
mental health with the help of an
experienced person you're one of those
million people
slide into my dms i date guys that go to
therapy
in fact so many people have been using
better help that they are recruiting
additional counselors in all 50 states
i'm available
special offer for good for you listeners
get 10 off your first
month at betterhelp.com whitney
great segway great segue into big love
do you remember when you were shooting
that and you were scared
didn't you have some crazy security
thing happen oh my gosh but that was the
very beginning i remember that you like
were like i'm scared to be at my house
okay
so we were warned ahead of time
because there were crazy things
happening in the news when we were
making the first
season and the show was not yet out and
there were
very real horrible you know
discoveries being made about this way of
life for people
um especially i'm the one that'll get
the best um and so
you know i mean and i'm talking about um
cult life i'm not talking about like
right like like recognize organized
religion right right life
um and so because there were these
things in the news
by the way this is like before we had so
many
like media and news outlets and social
media and like
so so we didn't have as much information
and we were told i remember by powers
that p that we need to to like
make sure we had good security systems
and
because we were going to be representing
something that people did not want
revealed right um or revealing things
that people didn't want revealed
so um i was scared in the beginning and
then realized it was all because then
nobody really
gave shit because by the way it's like a
tv show i know i i remember
i have security issues i'm like we're
like people know who you are like what i
don't know i was so
and it wasn't yeah we weren't worried
about like paparazzi we were worried
about
yes yeah it was being worried about like
these people being very angry because we
were representing real people and just
gave them of course yeah there was a lot
of emotion
um and and there were a lot of like
arrests and busts at the time and so
anyways
once the show actually started airing we
realized like there's nothing there's
nobody cares
they don't have hbo no they're not going
to watch do you remember when you
put smiley faces on your pasties oh my
gosh i still do this by the way
so new 100 still do that nudity writers
this is a laura lenny thing she taught
me this
tell me i mean i didn't i mean i i
haven't worked with her but she told me
this like she's jean trippon's best
friend we had dinner one night and she
told me this
that when you shoot a nude scene if in
your nude contract it says you cannot
show my nipples you wear
little pasties yes because there are
loopholes now i am
by the way i'm the only person i know
that reads every word in my contract
for sure i read everywhere i read every
word in my husband's contract
no one is seeing my husband's day right
so and i'm big on
i mean my poor lawyers because i'm like
i think i should i want this extra class
and they're like that doesn't exist i'm
like
it does now um but i need everything in
writing but um
but so there is a loophole and it is in
writing that um
if if you have a nudity clause which by
the way sag has really taken care of us
at this point like now
now like they call it sag because
they're talking about what we look like
babies um the uh
i feel like sag now has made it so they
have to you know jump
over other hurdles to get us to be naked
but it used to not be that way
and so in my nudity clause it would say
do i need to do that by the way right
now
what oh no i need to i just started
crying when you talked about some things
so now my makeup is coming off
do i look crazy no not at all so i'm
just doing that at all but i get like a
lot of mascara underneath so you can
tell maybe like a tiny one on this side
up yeah yep right here my new victoria
beckham
give them something we'll get send send
us some product oh my gosh your makeup's
insane no that's good the eyeliner is
like the best thing i've ever used
thank you um so uh i'm always trying to
be moist and so my mascara
um what laura lenny told me to do was
just
write now they don't want you to write
all of the pasties the pasties are
flesh colored on purpose they want them
to look like your body
yeah they're accidentally caught on
screen and the same for
the down below parts they're supposed to
look like if you get a flash of it you
don't think about it
yes it's supposed to have a nude pasty
you could kind of
it could get away yes yeah but instead
i went to that sticker place at the
grove and got loads of stickers
or sometimes i would use those and
sometimes i would take uh
like a permanent marker and i would
write all over the place i still do this
i just write on them now because i'm too
lazy to get the stickers
um i also just don't think stickers
don't stick as well as they used to have
noticed my kid's stickers but um
but um and those are so moisturizing oh
well this could be
but i write on i write on the pasties
things like stop looking at my boots
yeah
there's no way jose and smiley faces and
stuff smiley faces and down below and
everything like you can't film me like
whatever i can fit on there
i will write so that it's truly unusable
so it's also cracked me up when people
like i remember there some publicist
sent me a press clip at one
point that was you know and we did see
jenny's body and did it i'm like
no you didn't like it's actually
impossible you've never seen it nobody's
ever seen it before we talk about dolly
parton
i do have to ask about your skin because
everyone's gonna freak out if i don't
ginny because then all i do is
moisturize my skin okay we need to talk
about that so also ginny is an alien
i think we should just preface this she
doesn't have pores i don't know what it
is
i don't know if it's the nashville water
as i get older tiny bit
your face is made of porcelain so just
let's
let's just preface that what do you put
on your face god bless you it looks
unreal
um you know what i'm fentan isn't her
skin wild
it's crazy it's crazy y'all are very
kind i'm like
like my grandmothers both are people one
my late grandmother
when my um 98 year old grandmother are
women who were and are stopped on the
street about their skin
like and my grandmother who just turned
98 the other day
told me when i was little that um
she said don't touch your skin just
don't touch it don't pop things don't
touch it don't over wash it
don't just leave it alone
and so i do feel like though i do a ton
to it
now what i do is i try to like nourish
it yes
i don't like mess with it see that's key
because i was at war you remember with
my skin for so long you're squeezing
you're popping you're leaving scars
you're putting drying lotions on yeah
just leave it alone and
i never over washed it by the way i
slept in my makeup for like the first 20
years of doing makeup
now i find foul but at the time uh
i was just lazy and listening to my
grandmother because it was like well now
i just found out that half your makeup
is expired
it has expiration dates and on
everything there's like this little
picture of a jar and a number of months
it can be
just learned that makeup expires dwight
was just asking me so we just went
through this i found out everything in
my house was
seriously expired so that was very funny
i've been putting moldy eyeliner into my
eyeballs for the past 20. i had like 10
year old like stinky
lipsticks but so now i take a permanent
marker and i write the date
everything says 8 20 because it was in
august of 2020 that i've now opened
everything and then you can put some in
the refrigerator see i didn't know i put
my creams in the refrigerator
right benton isn't that your face
lotions yes but that doesn't make it
last any longer did you make that any
louder
how did you make this do you think i
built this is it just that like your
skin
tightens because it's colder it's just
yeah it just it like shocks your skin so
it gets deeper into your skin and things
like that
but my crease don't you make me put the
tata harper in the fridge i don't make
you do anything
um it's just it doesn't make it last any
longer it's just the cooling effect
makes the product work better benton's
mad because he gave me a birthday
present i haven't opened it yet
truly you should open my birthday party
i am going to downstairs but i'm so
awkward about opening presents no but by
the way mine's not like it's 20 20 and i
i'm sort of honoring like the craziness
of the world i didn't do anything
fancy did you get me a vaccine that
would be amazing uh
the i made you something best gift i've
ever gotten besides your
lemon marmalade uh well you've got more
of that
that you made me from the lemons on my
tree but i've got better one downstairs
and uh the first pair of real shoes that
i ever got
were from ginny oh i love this shoes i
remember those shoes from barney's on my
birthday
probably 26. yeah and i only wore
clothes from buffalo exchange
and like flea markets and that's where i
was before the interventions
yes yes but i would wear like um velcro
sneakers and crazy stuff because i
thought it would save time yeah
i'll do that okay i don't need your lip
benton
how dare you now they're like you i
don't need these two tennessee people
uniting against me um but uh and you
and dory bought me a pair of like
mew-mew black flats yeah
i wore them truly every day for like
seven years do you remember the ones
that i wore
that had holes in them and i kept taking
them to jenny when jenny first started
getting successful
she was like we we had to get her to
stop wearing like aldo
clogs and we had to like we're like
you're a sex symbol now you're a movie
star
this is ridiculous like you can't wear
dickies overalls anymore
to premieres
jenny would wear like bell bottom like
moo moose you were always in mumus and
like capes for some reason it was like a
total disaster
like she had a shirt that had like an
owl on it like like on the shoulder we
were like you can't you're a star you
can't do this
lots of onesies lots of onesies they
were so easy remember the pink onesie
you had like a baby pink
well it was a pink sweater that went
over the gray onesie right but it was
like a large sweater that would wrap
around
and then she would wear these like crocs
like like fancy flat crocs like
moccasins you had a lot of moccasins
oh my god i love them i know and then
where am i going with this
oh my shoes that had the holes in them
when i started getting started getting
money and started working like okay
you're a star you can buy things now
which is actually so funny because i
remember the first time you went and
bought a necklace with hearts on it
you drove away from the store and your
business manager went up turn around
yeah yeah
stuart he was like did you need to go
shopping at barney's can you go return
that and she went i just bought this
necklace now i have to go return it no
and i remember that heart necklace was
amazing i still have it i remember it's
broken but i still haven't have it
happening
someday i'll get it repaired but also i
remember saying things
i've said things to stuart in the past
like but i knew but you know but the
stylist told me that i needed it for
such-and-such and his answer is
is the stylist helping you pay for it
see this is why britney spears is on a
conservatorship because of
these type of decisions and so jenny
went and bought her first
nice pair of shoes they were baby pink
yes with little clothes on them chloe
our favorite
and she was wearing them and they kept
falling apart and she kept getting them
resold and i remember being like
as a broke person i like if you buy
expensive shoes shouldn't you
shouldn't they stay like why do you have
to reach that was the thing that made me
so angry yeah
and i would get them painted they
couldn't even dye them they had to paint
them and then the paint would crack
and i was going to this fancy place to
get them done in beverly hills and i
remember
asking the guy about it and he said you
wear these outside
i was like well yes and he goes you just
wear these to impress your friends when
they come over
oh but he was like these are inside
shoes yeah and i was like i wear these
to go on walls they were like nice
slippers
and she would go hiking in them i would
wear it because i refused
that but i still like once you've gotta
be like i'm wearing these everywhere
because i'm the opposite of you got
black too
a lot of people yes a lot of people i
feel like buy nice things or
that we're actresses and we're gifted
these nice things and they don't they
like
i mean they take better care of them
yeah but my whole thing is like if i
have it i'm going to wear it today
that's oh yeah no i'm aware
i was literally going through photos of
us because i was like had this whole
plan to like
show you a bunch of photos from our past
but i was too afraid to
upload them because i didn't want them
to go in the cloud fair enough because i
have so many weird nudes
yeah in my clouds i just didn't want to
um do that and i was like looking
through all these photos of us and
there's like mul i was getting confused
because we were wearing the same outfits
so many consecutive new year's eves
you can't even tell the difference
between 2006 and 2007
we wore the same clothes all the time
yes we did like we had our dresses our
flats and you had
really long hair that was parted in the
middle i know i'm trying i'm working on
it that was so wild
my hair long again okay so what are you
putting on your skin oh um
i mean like literally you want it like
literally oh wow oh yeah that would be
riots if we don't
um i first of all i really am one of
those people who's like you better be in
sunscreen
it makes my kids my kids hate it
so much that i like there's just no
reason to go outside if you're not
wearing something which one you wear
um right now i'm okay so i really like
this
there's a dermatologist on the east
coast i have never met i have never
worked with and i love his products
because when i was
postpartum with hugo i
my skin i feel like i've only
had like relatable normal skin
issues right during and right after
pregnancy right so my skin did not like
me being pregnant just like i had
problems with me being pregnant my skin
had problems with me i was not a happy
pregnant person
um love the kids just the pregnant part
then pose part and part that i struggled
with um were you sad after
i was but my sadness was not like i did
not have postpartum depression
so i can't relate to that um i had major
i'd like just identity issues yeah like
self-esteem issues based on i don't know
who i am when i look in the mirror
because it was like it was a i gained
so much weight during both of my
pregnancies
um and it wasn't it wasn't even fun it
was like
compulsive but also because i always had
um i was like someone who had morning
sickness
all the time but i wasn't throwing up so
i felt like it was worse i just
always felt sick and then i just ate
because when i would eat
i didn't feel sick so i gained an
enormous
amount of weight didn't know like i
couldn't recognize myself kind of weight
and that made me i just felt horrible
about myself
no one else made me feel horrible about
myself and like
my husband is like he he would have been
fine
making out with me at at any weight like
does nothing but make me feel like a
million bucks but
i know he's obsessed with you it's gross
no but but it's my own thing and i'm
like i have to feel we all have to just
feel good about ourselves
um so and i had really big issues with
all of the changes that my body went
through then afterwards and the
realization that like i couldn't
i don't know i felt out of control for
the first time in my life
of like every like my body's always been
a choice whatever state my body has been
in has always been a choice
and suddenly i felt like this wasn't
this was out of my hands um
so i also think i remember this
happening with
um our friends and you where when you
after you had your baby and after dory
had her baby i remember going oh leave
them alone they're really busy
right and i talked to george and i was
like i was like going through a hard
time cause i was like well i haven't
seen ginny and dory because they're you
know they both just had kids and they're
really busy and she's like you haven't
seen them and i was like well no i mean
they just had kids they're probably like
exhausted and she was like
you have to go see them they need to see
adults oh yeah so new moms
yeah they're just dealing with this
little slug that they can't communicate
with and all of a sudden you're like not
around
like friends and you're not getting like
socializing with girlfriends oh yeah
because i thought i was like leaving you
guys alone
oh yeah no and everybody does and like
because it is because it's mayhem
yeah it's like i don't want to add to
her plate i don't want to like put more
pressure than she already had but i
remember
um like one of the i mean i could cry
thinking about it and she probably
doesn't think it was any kind of big
deal but when i had hugo and i was in
the hospital
dory showed up at the hospital like the
next day
and because we already had a kid at home
i wasn't letting josh stay with me
at the hospital i was like you have to
go home and be with oliver
yeah i will be fine i've got 400 nurses
and dory showed up at the hospital and
she had snuck in
jars of moscow mules by the way i'm
categorically i'm on
like medication like i'm not allowed to
be drinking and she was like let's get
drunk
and that was like i mean i could cry
because it was so it was
everything i needed which is just like
we're still us
you know yeah like we'll get through
this yes but you probably want to forget
your you for a minute so i'm going to
help facilitate that
and and this thing that now makes all
your decisions for you well that's a
thing too it's like so not only was i
looking in the mirror and i didn't
recognize myself
but i also and i feel like i aged very
quickly and i'd always been like
aging in hollywood like it's such a like
that phrase it's a you know i felt like
that was like a
cliche yes and also like about the the
generation
older than us but all of the sudden
all of a sudden i was feeling it all at
once and i felt the i like mourned i
would cry i felt like i was mourning the
loss of my career
because all of a sudden i had to say to
my reps endlessly no
no no i was gonna say i said the girl
that passes on everything
no but no i mean god bless like i'm so
lucky but i've had to
like all of my decisions are based on
now staying home with my kids
and then there's all kinds of things as
you know i have like my laundry list of
things that like
have my or my checklist of things that
have to be met for me to take a job
but it is all about my children because
i am going to be home with them and i am
not going to work long hours
and they are not being pulled out of
school and all of these things so
um but skin wise i so when i was
postpartum with hugo i felt like
i was trying all kinds of different
things and i
spent a fortune and just had everything
everything was just being shipped to
canada and i was trying to like i was
like fix my skin fix my skin fix my skin
and i got really into this doctor's line
he's named
dr colbert do you know him he's on the
east coast stephen colbert
that'd be amazing that's the only
dermatologist
gasoline right that's what i'm supposed
to be putting on my skin
no but he's the opposite of a
dermatologist so he
his line and it was just one of those
things where i was trying a million
different things
and you know there were like i don't
know some actress girlfriend in new york
who like went and saw this dermatologist
and and so i started using his products
and i swear my skin cleared up
immediately and so i am kind of obsessed
with his stuff
and someday i'll you know see him when
he's on the like he knows i want to see
him if he's ever on the west coast yeah
um but i think his products are genius
but i do
i moisturize a lot like a couple times a
day
oh yeah i mean well with his stuff so i
so
his moisturizer okay so like morning
time
oh gosh so morning time i may or may not
wash my face it depends on like the time
of year
and like how i slept and how many
children were rolling around on me
okay um so i might just use water in the
morning
i know um and then uh
but apparently that's fine um and then i
do
i use one i use his serum and then i'll
use his day cream and then i'll do
some of his oil but only in certain
places and the eyes yeah and like
like here yeah yeah because i find that
like i do get clogged pores if i do at
other places with everything that
everybody says doesn't clog
it'll happen so yeah just avoid it clog
your quote pores no but something
happens
right something happens and then i'll
put on sunscreen
okay through his because he's part of
this group called the new york
dermatology group yeah they have a
sunscreen so i just put on that
sunscreen because i'm like well it must
all work together yeah that's right but
he also has like these pads i use all
his shit because he's got
these cold oh i see it yeah dr colbert
he's hot
i use these like have you seen him i
mean oh well he's kind of handsome
i don't think that's him by the way oh
yeah that's a different one oh okay
um
[Music]
md yes that's it right there's silver or
the silver bottles okay and there's also
like toning pads
yeah facial pads i use all of it protect
day lotion
packaging all of it okay okay and then
at night
i do wash my face no matter what at
night okay with his stuff and
then i'll do like night cream and i oh
i've used lemaire since i was like in my
20s i remember that
the lemare people i would go to the
counter back when we didn't buy online
and they would always tell me that i
should not be buying lemaire um and that
it wasn't for my skin type but it's the
only
and i was also really young and it's the
only thing that has
like kept my eyes moist for some reason
or just the original now i've graduated
to the like
like the big girl stuff because i'm you
know 42. um so now i'm on
like the darker container and you just
like pat that right you don't rub that
one in no
and then i use a lip mask at night oh
really
which one what the the lumiere one what
was the brand yeah not that one laneige
what's the one that no it's another one
pink
begins with the t it's japanese oh tacho
yes
yes lip mask i put lumira all over my
hands
really on the top of your hands yes are
you doing oh i also will use like toner
on my hands oh okay
these are the tricks that we live for on
this there is this i'm so mad
you can't get boots brand here right the
boots british
anyone's listening english people and
what do you need i will send a thank you
to anyone who can there's this
okay so it sounds so gross but it's so i
use it every day you're probably by the
way
categorically not supposed to use this
every day boots makes this cracked heel
bomb
cracked heel bomb let's get it i there's
nothing better
i'm sure that you're just supposed to
use this for cracked heels i just use it
for foot cream
i just put it on my butthole and i use
it all the time there's probably a limit
to how much you're supposed to use it
like it's a therapist it's like supposed
to be therapeutic i use it like foot
cream because i think it is
you put socks on over it yeah i love
foot cream with socks oh and bed socks
now that i can darn socks don't throw
out your bed socks will you explain what
darn socks is
okay well i have it so you've probably
read it right in any piece of literature
right like someone was darning socks
again i told you we have nothing in
common
ginny's bookshelf is full of vintage
shakespeare books oh yeah actually
literally she just like will just like
i'll come over and she'll just be like
reading like you know a doll's house
like a vintage show like ibsen play but
you're like
pentameter is really good like the kids
can do it yeah i don't know what she's
even saying i've had to go see her in
shakespeare plays i've had to go to
williamstown to watch her do all this
literacy shit
if you drove so far i did drive to
williams i make you do my stuff for the
library where even
was william brochures the berkshires and
massachusetts in massachusetts we drove
to watch ginny be brilliant
in a play it was so fun jenny is
literate as fuck no
i got to show you a video that oliver
made we had to do this project for
school that was supposed to be about his
culture
and what they really wanted was ancestry
us to make a video about ancestry i
could not get him interested
which broke my heart because i'm
obsessed with our ancestry
um and but when i was talking to him
about what
culture is i included language and so he
goes oh let's do spanish
and i was like well honey we don't speak
a word of spanish though i love that we
speak english and he said oh let's film
our library that's full of english
and i was so happy that i didn't
correct him and i told the teachers i
was like sorry but we did our own thing
no but i'll show you the video after of
that he made that he was so proud
showing off the books in our library and
like our and like the
dictionaries and stuff because we and i
you know work with the um
la public library and um anyways and he
loves all of that but
uh especially he's my bookworm but um
start talking about this we were talking
about this well
and pentameter i am big pentameter ready
darning socks
sucks because everybody in classic
literature darn socks and now okay so
you know jimmy is an amish woman
uh and i have a better churn now
we need to get you a cotton gin yeah so
what is
darning socks is when you sew up a hole
okay so that's the thing
if you okay have you ever taken a
sweater i'm gonna get jenny
um have you ever taken it like a nice
sweater to the dry cleaner
and they say like you have a hole in
this would you like us to send it to a
darner
no you don't talk about it when you take
your sweaters
okay so darning is shockingly easy as i
took an
um online zoom course recently
at seven in the morning in my pajamas um
and it's basically patching so it's not
sewing up it's patching
knit but the idea is you either want it
to contrast significantly for
like expressive artistic reasons right
or you want it to blend in completely
with
the knit of what has been torn because
if you sew up
knit it's going to change how it pulls
and you're going to always be able to
tell yeah
but if you it's sort of like inserting a
puzzle piece of knit
yes okay jenny's a sweater surgeon so i
need a vaccine
i'm a sweater a surgeon why did we start
talking about this
because you're darning now i know but
how did we start talking about darling
because
something else like skin and how about
putting
your stuff on your feet and putting
something oh the size okay so bedside so
i sleep like a granny
and i because i like like my favorite
place to buy night games you know from
rock country
get a vermont country store right
nightcounts look like um
look like with zombies and horror movies
wear like in haunted houses
they probably like like like on the
exorcist like
it's like a sweat let me guess it's a
it's a night out that has like a
lace turtleneck well those are amazing
in the winter yeah um but you want no
but i especially like like the flannel
with like apples and hearts
what is it vermont country store has the
best
and like house like like if you want
like a like a house coat like
yeah jenny fully has like um a little
house on the prairie
uh full look at their nightgowns these
hold on why are you looking at from i
don't want vermont hold on this is a
vermont country store i feel like yeah
you wear apple butter to bed look at
their uh
website vermont country i'll go to store
gown oh god jenny these are creepy these
are what like women got murdered in and
like in the civil war night gowns
curtains or curtains and nightgowns look
the same should i just go to curtains
night gown yeah it's a true gown
all right so now oh so i sleep in these
okay
and long johns don't bully her you
understand three-piece suit
i dress like annie hall to go to school
you
used to wear ties all the time i
loved it even on red carpets i'm sure my
publicist was like that was also perfect
jennifer goodwin todd that was like
prior to having a style jenny used to
wear a white oxford shirt with a black i
was like well it looks dressed up she
was like marcel marseille
she looked like a cheesecake factory
hostess like you're a celebrity
oh look at that night count okay jenny
this one yeah
okay this is my favorite this is a full
turtleneck
that's not really the one this is a is
that a snuggie or a slanket
like there's like some of them are like
flannel
like this kind of thing jenny these look
haunted
these look like oh i have
there's a challenge he likes having to
find me under all the layers i'll wear
like these long john like i wear these
like
long johnny pants and then i wear like i
like cashmere bed socks
but that i can darn them now so i put on
the foot cream and then i put on the bed
socks but if i wear holes in them now i
can darn them
don't have to throw them out any longer
could we be more different
could we do i do hand washing that shit
can you believe this is my favorite
thing won't even be broken and when he's
like get another one
like i recommend i do like the doing it
in a different color
oh like um like raggedy yeah like what i
showed you too yes
yes she had a pair of brown socks with
like pink stitches yeah where the whole
where you make the
yeah it's fun because you can really be
like a more expressive can you believe
we're friends that's a lot
my favorite thing to knit though by the
way is like like speaking of this i also
love like a good
coat like a hot water bottle cozy
like this is how i sleep josh has to get
past the hot water bottle
you're so wet no that's just my my
old-timey
civil war medicine plastic
my whoopee cushion that's full of water
like those old ones
oh yeah better i'm good that's a movie
kitchen do you not use a hot water
bottle i don't know
i do heating pads i don't know we stay
warm for so long you can sleep with them
you don't have to like worry about
burning the house down mm-hmm
they're so comfy like the cat on you
put them on their feet at night the kids
have them
[Laughter]
okay talking about dolly parton oh yeah
so i watched heartstrings this weekend
it made me cry it feels good it made me
cry
i i ca i cannot believe it made me cry
uh there's so few things that like you
don't see the twist coming or you don't
see
the heartbreak coming or you don't you
know it was just like i i guess i just
um wasn't expecting to get so emotional
about it but it is dolly parton's
show based on her song absolutely every
song
is the every song is based on
i mean sorry not every time every
episode is based on a different song's
narrative yeah she's a very she's very
much a storyteller
and so it lends itself to tv episodes
but and then ours was the
first so kathleen turner and i did the
first i'm sorry you know that kathleen
turner
the first time i ever saw him her was at
williamstown totally when i saw your
play and i saw her in the lobby and i
almost fainted
and i was like it's virginia no she i
also like
i mean i'm she's brilliant all right
she's brilliant but let me ask you jump
in front of a bus
you're obviously jennifer goodwin but
watching her those scenes where she was
like in the courtroom with the bones and
stuff
was it ever was there ever a moment
where you're just like that's fucking
kathleen turner
she i mean you work with such famous
people but there's something about no by
the way i mean she's
she's half of why i did it it was i mean
i was sent the you know the breakdown of
the
of the offer and it was dolly parton and
kathleen turner yeah
well i don't even have to i'll be there
and i will be nude
yeah no you can see me naked all my
closets go out the window right
no and and i mean by the way i do
believe like kathleen turner is now
friend for life which as we know does
not happen
on many a set yeah you don't just like
make a friend for life from a set
um like she comes to town and like like
we go on dates
and then when she is back in new york
where she lives and josh has to be there
for manifest i'm like you call kathleen
you take her out you take her flowers
i feel like she's just a a beacon of
infinite wisdom a hundred percent
and she's just like she's also by the
way like
i don't know she's like this warm magnet
like i just want to be around her
but she also terrifies me i was scared
of her before i got to know her for sure
like the first time we met i think it
must be
easily the biggest sex symbol when i was
growing up like my brother had posters
of her on his wall
so she's also like own award-winning yes
like critically acclaimed war of the
roses is
i mean still maybe my favorite movie
she's oh
so the first time i met her was at the
read through
i think yeah it was at the read through
i mean truth be told i had met her
at williamstown a million years before
but i didn't count that because
i don't know we didn't like it was just
like a in passing someone introduced us
at a party yeah
part of me so she has coveted i've
covered um
you're the only person i've seen in six
months that's true we have coveted worth
it
i have been you are my bubble break um
you are 100 my bubble breaker well by
the way also this is how close friends
jenny and i are she kind of tried to
reschedule this and i said no
and i so appreciated it and i needed to
get out of the house because i was like
i i realized i was having severe
separation anxiety yes
because other than going to the doctor
by the way with my children
i haven't been away from my children for
any period of time in six months
wow and uh the way
and you can leave at any time this is
going weird i'm done
right now i'm like no please give me
your please no but it was really
interesting to realize too like oh i
need to get out of the house like and we
have said no to everything because of
you know also as you know as whitney
knows like you know local family that's
super high risk and things like this so
we've just been like we are going to be
we're responsible for other people but
whitney goes above and beyond with all
the protocols and so
we felt safe with me doing it but also i
was like i haven't been around another
human being i know it's so weird and we
and it's this is i
this is there's maybe two people in my
life that were close enough to do this
she's like
maybe we should do this next week like i
felt it and i felt it too like i've
almost rescheduled every
thing that i'm doing because i start
panicking like at the last minute sure
and just being like oh let's do it later
i was like i've got to brush my hair
i know she was like i don't know i have
to brush my teeth like i did i have to
take off my
my crib keeper pajamas and his spoon and
she was like should we do it next week
and i was like no we're keeping it and i
was like great
i was like this is my birthday present
but i felt real relief after
after we went i realized too i think and
i'm sorry to have put you through that
no can i tell you glad that we then did
because i
realized then like oh i'm relieved that
i'm going no but i loved it because to
me it was like
it means so much to me when i can be
authentic around somebody and our
relationship means so much to me the
fact that
i just went no let's keep it or like no
and even josh said like he said i didn't
feel scared i didn't feel a pit in my
stomach i didn't think you're gonna be
mad at me yeah i didn't think it was
going to make things
awkward it was going to be a thing yeah
i was like no you're my birthday present
you're coming but i think too
it saved it from me like being resentful
this morning that i hadn't said
something
do you know what i mean yeah like
because we had the full-blown discussion
about it
yes then coming here was like a delight
instead of me still going through that
this morning getting dressed going like
why didn't i say something
yes yes yes yes which is something josh
actually said to me days ago wisely it
was like you're going to resent this if
you don't
have a conversation with her like it's
just gonna then
i knew how much of a hassle this was for
you and i made you do it anyway but then
it was like i have to do it so good i
know i'm excited to go
but no now i feel like i've been hurt
and i've been seen
yeah i said it was like just bring the
kids we'll throw them in the pool yeah
they're staying home there she's like i
don't have child care and i was like i
don't care i didn't have child care when
i was a kid i turned out fine
i was like just look at this
um oh kathleen so kathleen i'm sorry i
get off on such like tangents that's
what a podcast is it's just
giant tangent i feel like because i feel
like now it's talk show where i'm like
wait i was supposed to be getting to
some point
um so i was scared of her
and she came up to me after the table
range she was like what are you doing
tonight
what are you doing yeah and i said um
i'm gonna
i'm gonna go to uh my hotel room
googling you i'm gonna yeah and i'm
gonna just like study for tomorrow and
i've gotta
you know i've got a costume finish was
like we're going to dinner
okay and she's like i'll text you later
so she texts me later
and i google them she's like i need you
to pick me up at such and such a time
like come to my house and then we're
going to take because she was on the way
and she's like then we'll take an uber
so can you imagine being an uber driver
and picking up kathleen turner
oh my god oh my god i know it's genius
oh my god and so but here's the thing
too not only did the uber driver pick us
up to take us but um he took
picked us up to take us an hour and a
half away
oh so i was like wait i'm gonna be in
the car with kathleen turner for an hour
and a half
like i was terrified and it was in that
hour and a half that i was like oh
you're
like this is something different where
we're gonna like right
spawn right and like through life we'll
be like touching base with each other
and
like instant family yeah like she's
special
and had you met dolly parton before this
no
growing up in tennessee was it like
she's she's got it
yeah she said um she is
everything you want her to be she is the
only
icon celebrity is an insult frankly the
only icon legend and stars benjamin
would say
legend star icon legend star who benton
has a
dolly parton tattoo
um uh who i have consistently heard
is over delivers
over delivers when you meet yes over
delivers she is dolly parton
all the time and the thing that floored
me the most
oh it's so good
that's a good dolly era too a good one
she's got a new christmas album coming
out you know i remember when you went to
go have dinner with
her oh yeah and you were like very
nervous i think i sent you all the
pictures yes yes yes you like them under
the table
was it like but she's instantly like i'm
dolly parton and we're not gonna make a
big deal about it wait here's the thing
she knows how she knows how to be what
you want her to be
so she knows like she is so
she immediately tells you the most
wonderful hysterical stories
that like feed into yeah what you want
her to be but then
this is what tripped me up
this i would ask her a question right
about herself
because i figured like a lot of the
major stars that i've been around
that mean and i was raised in the south
like you should ask them about
themselves like there's
that's all they want to talk about
and by the way i'm really good on a set
with big stars because
you know how to make them feel like the
center of attention i'm totally fine not
being the center of attention
like i really am like one of the
greatest compliments i've ever gotten
was from sam jaeger who was in why women
killed with me last year right
and he said he knew that we were going
to be friends
when we got to set and he realized that
i wanted to work and go home
and he was like you're not looking for
like anything like anything
outside of like let's get along there's
a job let's respect each other but like
i'm gonna work and i'm gonna and by the
way i'm gonna know
all of my lines before we get this out
this is the only job where
like some people maybe 90 of people show
up having no idea what they're doing
or memorizing anything and they get to
just flirt for 40 minutes
between working yeah no i'm we're gonna
i'm gonna be the first person on set
because i wanna roll
yeah and by the way this was also a
julia roberts thing that i watched her
always do this
and then when you do show up and are
prepared and ready to go people are like
she's a bitch and you're like i i'm
literally just the only person here
who's prepared
but i will also i find like at this
point i can also have conversations with
other actors like especially younger
actors at this point like at
like get go i can be like i would love
it if we had a set
where yep let's just i will run lines
with you anytime you want but let's
know those before we even get to work in
the morning
what you got paid to do it's a little
impossible i want to get home for dinner
with my children
this is a job no yeah it's not camp yeah
no no no it's not camp and we're not a
college no and we're not going to go to
a dorm after this
i've got a life that is way more 200
people here waiting for us to go home to
there
well you were asking about like like i
mean in other words like balance and
priorities and
and like self-knowledge what's balance
like i
my real life is so much better than my
work life
and that will always come first my real
life is
is my work life supports my real life
not the other way around
wow that's everything to me it is all
about me getting home
i wanna i wanna get home for dinner um
and when i was younger i was like that's
okay
yes i'll stay here until three in the
morning because you're doing whatever in
your trailer and like now i'm like
hey hey hey like yeah you are like i
don't know i just have like really
strong boundaries and i'm really good at
expressing them
yes that's so cool but um but
uh and by the way it benefits everybody
boundaries benefit
everybody yeah everybody everybody's
wearing for every
boundaries everybody knows where your
lines are it makes it all so much easier
that's right
but yeah kathleen so kathleen turner was
immediately friend like immediately
mm-hmm um so i st she stopped wait what
was the dolly parton thing that tripped
you up that's right
that's what it was it's the it's the
dolly
right it's that
we're having dinner this is like your
only six-hour podcast we're having
dinner
and uh i would say so
uh you know tell me about okay here's
just
like start off example as in this was
the first question that i asked her like
break the ice example was
um i asked her about old bones because
the story that we are telling
in the episode these old bones which is
the tv movie that then
like launches the series because the
rest are episodes and this was the tv
movie
um and it's based on
a real-life woman that dolly knew and so
the first question i asked was about
bones the real-life woman because i
thought that was might be a good
icebreaker
and she answered it and then immediately
said to me
have you ever known anyone like this in
your life tell me about that person
and then and like kept doing that
over the course of dinner where whatever
it whatever
topic we were you know touching upon she
would then
instead like turn it around and be like
well how did that make you feel
i mean she was interested i didn't know
what to do yeah
like i must have dealt with famous
people clinical narcissists
but she's i mean it's unbelievable
because it also none of it felt
contrived
it felt so authentic like she
because then she would have follow-up
questions and she would get excited
about certain things that like were part
of my story
you know something about my parents or i
mean that blew my mind and i think that
there's no coincidence that she's dolly
parton
yeah the type of people that are
actually interested in other people make
the best art
absolutely she's really watching she's
really listening
where did you guys go yeah i don't know
something set up by like the movie
people it wasn't like a restaurant
like can she go to restaurants it was
closed for us yeah like we do
you know how they close restaurants for
us like before the pandemic
um no but what was crazy was so it was a
you know it was like
people involved in the project were
going and and the
the person who takes care of dolly had
come up to me and said
i don't get like i won't get in trouble
for saying this but it had said like hey
we're not telling anybody but like you
are dolly's date so like you guys are
going to go sit together and da da da da
da da
what kind of like i'm going to be in the
car with kelly turn it for an hour and a
half i can't
um yeah so i was like coming trying to
come up with smile like amazing and by
the way she
looks like she looks like dolly parton
up close do you know what i mean like
there's no like
i don't know you're not like oh i see
the strings no like i see them
like and she says she is dolly parton at
six in the morning if she's going to the
bathroom she's wearing six
six inch heels i mean there are times
when she has like another version of her
life because she also is very clear that
like she has boundaries and i was not
about
does she have flip-flops like does she
wear moccasins or what does she wear to
bed
no but she knows how to be undercover i
will say without disclosing how because
i think that that was secret but i mean
the way that she described it to me but
um
but she she knows yeah how to be dolly
parton and a story that she loves
telling
is that she went to one of like she said
one of the biggest like compliments to
her
in her life was she went to in west
hollywood um a look-alike dolly parton
contest
and she entered and she lost and she
said it could not have made
her happier like watching these people
that had like taken on her
persona and that it was like helping
them in some way and like working for
them and that they did it better than
she did
she like loved this shit that's the
greatest thing i've ever heard isn't
that amazing
but you know she's special like she's oh
and you've seen i've talked till i
showed what like
my favorite christmas card i've ever
gotten oh i've got a frame it's from
doll it up
it's my favorite ever and the i love
that the um it's a christmas card like
that was mailed
yeah it's for friends and it's the the
return return address just said like i
think it just says dolly parton and like
nashville
like it just says no it just says dolly
parton nashville tennessee yeah
and i i mean i was plus-sized there's no
address
yeah like you know where to find me like
i told a mutual friend of ours that i
was like
dolly's got the new christmas album
coming out i just bought the holly dolly
christmas
uh sweatshirt and he was like oh dolly's
gonna love that and i was like that's
such a weird thing to get
like that's such a weird like dolly's
going to be told that i bought her
like dolly barton sweatshirt
we never um finished the story about ice
oh my gosh you have to tell the ice
store okay so
this is just full circle when jenny met
me i
was so crazy i mean i was just a mess
like i was
a mess i had not been like parented i
didn't know how to take care of myself i
didn't know how to put myself first i
was always losing my keys i was always
losing my credit card i was always like
my car like had a boot on it like my
license was expired like i didn't have
health insurance like i was just like
oh my gosh you didn't have health
insurance i was just a mess like genius
who told me
savings are for emergencies 100 remember
that
savings because i would then they're not
for purses they are for emergencies like
she's like savings are for
like dental surgeries yeah or like your
cat is sick
or your savings you have to jump on a
plane and go see a family member yeah
so even later when i started saving
money i was like oh my god i saved this
amount of money i'm gonna buy this purse
she's like no no savings are for
savings dental emergency yes yeah this
is not a luxury
thing and so i was just i was like just
such a mess was just always something
with me
and i was calling them like two in the
morning like i can't find my keys i
don't know my guy like lose my car in
parking lots
like i don't remember i parked next to a
green truck and i can't find it they're
like you know cars move
you can't remember where your car is on
another based on another car like i was
just
um in the clouds and in bad
relationships the whole thing and so
one time we were emailing i feel like i
was maybe like 28 or 29
this is i'm trying to remember what
quote you had in your email at the time
i
believe i believe was holly a harry
potter quote because jenny i kind of
know
where she is in her life based on the
automatic sign-off quotes
it was harry potter for really she had
it was harry potter for a long time it
was audrey hepburn for a long time yeah
where you would email jenny and you'd
get like an inspirational quote in the
email so you like think twice about
cancelling on it
so it just like shames you based on
whatever email you're sending
whatever disappointing thing you're
writing and i remember she emails me and
two of our other
best friends and in the
[Music]
i didn't know it was going to show up so
literally
i i respond to the email and i'm
emailing them and we're emailing about
like making a plan together
and our other two friends emails next to
their name
says the word ice it was probably dory
and my sister i think it was dory and
your sister and maybe celine yeah maybe
and in parentheses it said i-c-e but
then next to my email it didn't say i
see
and i didn't know how to and i didn't
know i didn't
know they didn't show up on anybody's
email because it was just how it was
entered in my phone
we're literally like emailing about like
a trip together so like email email and
then
what's ice i write back i'm like what's
ice and it's
silence
but then there was a day that you did
make ice so i was
not someone that was programmed in as an
in case of emergency contact which i
learned
that's what ice means so i was just did
not make it but we were like
we should be your ice that's the thing
you were my i remember when i had to go
feed your cat
oh my gosh i
i mean i think i made like a tutorial
like a vhs tape or do something for me
all i had to do was feed her cat it's
literally all i had to do was put some
kibble in a bowl yeah
you brought me a written out piece by
step
to turn on and off my alarm which by the
way i am one of those people that's like
really basic there's not
if this is not mission impossible no and
it was like right now i'm like jenny's
so like neurotic like she wrote out
like 17 steps of how to go into her
house turn the alarm off feed the cat
leave reset the alarm i'm like god like
what is so patronizing like why doesn't
she
take me seriously like i can open a
fucking garage door
and you're on vacation so the police
called and they're asking who whitney is
i could not figure out but i don't know
what it was like and i was thinking
i was like but it's whitney no i was
like i was like the police you were like
but it's whitney i'm whitney i was
against whitney i'm her friend
she gave me the code but like you know
what ginny is like likely story i
sounded like i was robbing your house
100 and i couldn't remember where you
were i was like no she went on a trip i
think she's
fuck she's in maybe like arrowhead i
remember them being like uh
you know we have to call the police
right i was like don't call the police i
promise i'm whitney i was like google me
and uh so then it took i want to say
like
six or so years ago i finally got
promoted to ice
which means i really made it yes i like
pulled
emergency contact actually i'm bad at
like just
normal things but emergencies is where i
shine
i feel like we've had we've gone through
good crises together
yeah we really have i was even thinking
about you know
like dory suffered a tragic loss
recently and i loved like that i could
call you
and you are exceptionally busy these
days but i could call you and be like
hey
can you be at my house in like 30
minutes because dory's having a hard
time and we're gonna
we're gonna talk to her yep yeah and i'm
there yeah yeah it's like there's
there's that
this like you and dory come before like
everything
like you're busy until you're not right
yeah i mean yeah i'm not busy
that's the thing suddenly there's so
much time i remember i was talking about
that in terms of relationships with dory
too about like
how it's with the wrong people that we
never have enough time well that's it i
mean the right people
it's like time is created somehow i'm
this man is texting me
and he's like i know you're really busy
i know you're really busy and i just had
to write back i don't have time i make
time
yeah so i don't do anything i don't want
to do but i don't like be
don't like do some weird math based on
my instagram and decide that i'm really
i am really busy but i will make time
for you
yes you know what i mean yeah we have
all the time in the world when it comes
to the right things yes
it does blow my mind that like you you
are like
to i would say like to comedy you are
like what
fouchy is to me with the pandemic you
are to me with like
comedy and like health in general how
wild is that isn't that
wild but you have seen firsthand that i
i did work my ass off i mean i am i was
in therapy
to think like you so hilarious hilarious
so but you saw me like starting to go to
alan on starting to go to therapy like
you
saw the whole trajectory yeah the whole
180. yeah
because now i'll call you to be like for
for all that i was like sending you
articles about hydration i'll call you
and be like what am i supposed to do
about those
no wild how can i make my life healthier
in this way and then i also turn to you
these days for anything regarding comedy
and i don't know anything it works like
it you can change i mean this is what we
talked about in the podcast last week
with
andrew huberman like you can change your
brain if i yes
if i can pull it together anyone can
you've seen it no you've written i mean
these little girls grown up
but aged backwards weirdly that that's
the health
that's the health and money and sleeping
yeah
and lasers lasers and derma rolling i do
like some lasers i do derma rolling
derma rolling i don't know what derma
rolling is but i like lasers i'll get
like veins like that i want zapped
no i did the um not the cool laser the
one that
the photo facial which ended up it just
takes like sunspots off you do not need
it at all
because you should be wearing sunscreen
i know i will after this
i don't you know what i i don't wear it
when i'm driving oh no we do knit when
we're driving that's where i got i was
like
my hands look very young i'm not even
gonna lie
yeah um even though someone was like uh
uh you
i went to a derby tower just like this
like six years ago or something
and uh and i went in because i was
working on a tv show and they told me i
had under eye bags and then i like
looked tired
and so i go to this like dermatologist
and he's like i walk in i'm like i look
tired i don't know what to do
and i pointed my eyes i was like don't
have eye bags and he's like your eyes
are fine but what are you going to do
about your hands
no i know i do feel like we neglect our
you can put botox in your hands
no i know i haven't done it yet but i
started wearing
gloves when i drive and sunscreen always
on my hands
oh yeah i heard john rivers used to do
that for qvc that tracks
oh yeah she would wear sunscreen she
would put botox in her hands
have you you've seen that documentary
piece of work right oh yeah joan rivers
documentary is amazing
i love it i never want to let you go but
i know you have a life
what time is it do i have to go no i'm
not going to tell you
you're officially neglecting your
children officially we need to call
chelsea i'm on i'm like
i'm letting you go right this second i'm
on i'm on parent duty oh yeah yeah
okay yeah you'll be okay and then um
what else
you're doing a tv show with one of my
favorite people oh my gosh that hasn't
come out yet
but i cannot wait speaking of you sent
me that pilot do you know this do you
remember this because i do have
something okay she has to do this yes i
remember
reading a pilot uh it was like in the
beginning of this year
who knows what it's going to be called
when it actually comes out right now
it's pivoting reading
written uh written this is i have lock
draw we've been talking too much
um written by one of my favorite writers
on the planet who wrote on the t
two tv shows that i did uh truly the
easily the funniest funniest person i
know she's unreal even texting
the funniest her name's liz astrology i
love you oh she has a book buy her book
she also has an amazing book
um and uh and she we used to work on a
tv show together
and she would she would she would leave
during lunch and go buy clothes down the
street
and bring it back and then the next day
being a shame spiral and return
no no no no no she's just like the
funniest
like i'd walk by on my home and she'd be
eating like salmon in her car
like she's loving it she's just
everything she's she's
she came up with some of the best two
bro girls episodes um
uh for the people that loved uh the nbc
show
with the splenda chicken that's liz
people will yell at me on the streets
sometimes and be like splendid chicken
which is very inside if you don't know
what it is but um
she makes me laugh harder than anyone
well this one so i was talking to you
about this is what i want
i am uh 42 years old
and i as we know want to have dinner
with my children and i'm not leaving la
and i would like to be laughing
i would like to if i'm crying i want it
to be making people laugh yeah
i feel like i do a lot of crying to make
people cry um and watching like every tv
show and every movie you were doing for
a longest time you were just like
god this is such a stressful job because
i was like losing my voice all the time
and i went to see this
um ear nose's throat specialist crying
and fucking and crying
and showing 20 of my touch i went to see
the specials because i was losing my
voice like twice a year and he said that
i had
i my bo he was like how stressful your
life i was like not at all
like the best life and he was like how
much do you cry on camera and i was like
oh that's uh
everybody wants me to cry on camera
everything i do and i'm always trying to
explain to directors and writers like
hey this doesn't make good acting just
because i can cry on camera
um like we could let's do something else
but everybody wants me to cry and he
said your body thinks that you are
living through the stress that your
characters are living through
and i was like exhausting this thing in
my throat and it meant that like i was
having bad acid issues and it was making
my
i was losing my voice all the time
anyways point being i was like i would
like to be la
i would like to if i'm gonna cry i want
it to be making people laugh and
generally i would like to just not be
crying as much yeah
um and and you but i said but here's the
problem with it is i have to be in la
i have to have a good schedule i have to
make a certain kind of income and the
writing has to be
spectacularly genius and that's a really
really really really
really tall order and you sent me
pivoting
and then by the way i called my reps i
was like why didn't you send me pivoting
yeah that's right i read it and i left
out loud and i was like this is i was
like
does whit need to be my presentation and
i gave it to my husband and he read it a
couple of times and laughed out loud
and then we started those talks in
february and then i didn't hear anything
and the pandemic
and i was like oh like you know the
pandemic hit so
like like work is over and we'll see
what happens on the flip side of crazy
stress and spiraling
and um over over you know work for
actors during a pandemic
as we cannot do it from home and um
and then all of the sudden weirdly i
don't remember what month it was when i
started texture and i was like this is
so weird like they had been negotiating
this whole time for like months yeah i
thought that it had gone away but i had
gotten the job
yeah and they were finishing the
contract about this business like half
the time even when you do
win they don't even tell you nobody you
can't even enjoy it
the few times that things are going well
by the way the dolly parton so my dolly
parton
tv movie was dominating you guys have
got to watch this oh thank you
yay and i didn't know so like i didn't
know
and like nobody's home can someone tell
me that i was nominated for an emmy
nobody told me
so i like sent a message to all of my
reps and i was like hey
guys guys like because you had one job
literally one job
i'm like we're all
um nomination not at me nomination but
um
but yeah nobody told me i was like
nobody told me i got the well actually
yeah i know
i know everybody's hollywood's so
glamorous like we don't know half the
shit that's going on out of the time
like it's just like
no yeah i was thinking about i mean how
glamorous things are
there's an emmy party that's virtual and
they were walking me through
you know like netflix is throwing this
virtual you know celebration
and so i was talking to people about
like yes i would need to like do my hair
and makeup and
i could just be dressed from here up and
be fine today i was like i don't have
child care
like that's how glamorous it is i don't
have child care so i cannot go like i'm
not going to sit there with my kids
and because i don't want my kids part of
things like i want them part of things
like they come with me to sets
because i want them to i'm really
hardcore about i want and i know we need
to go
um i will do this truly all day and i
need to go actually i just
i just want you to go see your kids so
they don't turn into community
well that's the thing they're like she
did actually ban enough yeah i don't
want them to she ran off
but i'm i'm hardcore with my kids about
since the beginning
um though we say things to them all the
time like well mommy and daddy have to
go to work because we have to do things
like
pay for school in disneyland yeah yeah
yeah but um
but i don't want it to be something i
don't want them to think it's like a
i don't know i don't want them to resent
the thing that
we have to do to support them and i want
them to see
that we are fucking lucky because we get
to do something we love for a living do
they get to know you're in
the voice in zootopia oh yeah well now
they figured it out because oliver was
getting really
that must be confusing yeah and we have
a doll
that somebody gave us that's i mean a
judy hopps doll that speaks and so he
would be
like mom say would you say this and then
he would like squeeze it and he was like
you sound a lot like that rabbit um
it was never that i was a rabbit it was
and and by the way never had questioned
before recently the fact that we have
like
you know original like zootopia art on
the walls but like no other
original sketch yeah we really do and
like no other
so he had seen zootopia before four
hundred thousand times
just suspected it was you no he i'm sure
i'm sure there was a subconscious
comfort that he found in the sound of my
voice that must have been so confusing
yeah hugo still doesn't understand okay
he talks about it like he does but he
doesn't
get it yes oliver truly is trying it my
sister's an animator he's trying to
understand
animation he understands i acted it and
then
it was animated but he also understands
that i was filmed while acting it and
that some of my movements were used that
he finds familiar
um no it's wild that is must be so
confusing it's so confusing i promised
him on the next movie and when he left
his his name's in the credits
because he was born during production
hugo's devastated i was like i don't
know i can't like
you know after the fact yes this issue
but um i promised them they could come
with me if we ever do a number two and
they could
you know be part of it but they do come
to sets so our thing is when we're going
away in the morning or when josh is
going to new york
we always remind them we hate being away
from you
but we are so lucky because we love our
jobs and if you work
really really hard and if you're lucky
enough
you will also do something that you love
for a job so
when mommy and daddy are away from you
it's because we're getting to
because we're because we're blessed you
can have someone trying to
put your nipple on camera without your
permission and you'll love every minute
of it
um so and also because of that it's
important to me that they be
made to feel like when they visit us on
sets that it is a celebration
so i generally ask like hair and makeup
people like will you
make my children feel fancy and so like
why would kill they would come to set
and like get press on nails and fake
mustaches
you know they would like you know the
catering person would like do something
for them and
we would get chairs set up for them at
the monitor and they would um
oh this is a thing all right there
here's my closer for you
um they came to
watch me film a scene for why women kill
which did not make the show
but in the scene i said
all men are capable of infidelity
and i had because of how we were editing
together
it was almost like a montage how we were
editing editing the scene together
i had to take line by line and just
repeatedly do the one line over and over
and over again and when they felt like
they got it i would do the next line
because they would
have another someone like spliced in who
was saying the next piece
what do you call that uh it's not a
monster it's like pops quick
yeah like like i would say one line
another actor would suddenly be in my
place saying the next line and we were
all telling the same story but it was
all edited together like
one like little monologue right and it's
like passing off the
yeah you know the lines and so i kept
saying this over and over again
and weeks later um he was saying
apparently at at the time preschool
all men are capable of infidelity and i
was very concerned about what people
would think was going on at our house
but he was listening
and that is the good news but yeah so
they sit there with
their headphones at video village and
they get all hooked up
and but i am realizing that i need to
pick and choose when they come see me on
set
i have a friend who her and her kid they
play this game where
she goes uh if you don't get in bed i'm
going to beat you
it's that stuff you then hear back later
and then they start laughing it's like
don't beat me
like i'm going to beat you and they'd
like do fake noogies and like don't make
me be yes
she said no they went to school and she
was like bye baby and he's like are you
don't beat me
and the teacher and she was like oh my
god this is a game we play but you want
to hear the worst
i heard oliver say once is i didn't even
realize this is so disgusting
that i used to say to him if he wasn't
listening to me do you speak english
[Music]
i heard him say it to someone and oh no
oh no i mean it gives me anxiety even
like thinking about it now
i could not believe that it took hearing
it come out of his mouth to realize like
what that what that sounded like a
gorgeous blonde hair boy
he is an anglo-saxon like he is
he could be nordic like he was a
horrible thing to watch come out of
somebody's mouth yes so we now said hey
buddy
um we actually can't say that ever again
and mommy will never say
that ever again truly ever again yeah no
truly i don't know why i don't know why
i said it like where i got it
like it was horrible but thank goodness
it happened
like the one time and will never happen
again because kids can change you can
change the rules on them and now that is
something we never say
we are allowed to be flexed yep i'm
gonna make you do this again i'm sure
for my birthday can we do this every
year
which is so not big how long have we
been friends 20 years almost truly
because you because we became friends i
mean it was right after i was 20
yeah i was maybe 22 and i'm turning 30.
it was
because it was right because dory and i
both moved here from new york the same
week oh you're friends with new york
that's right we weren't best friends but
we had just we were new friends that's
right that's right
and separately moved here together the
same week that's right
and then we remember when we made up
fake names for each other oh my god do
you remember what yours was no
daddy
i was blanche i think yeah what was she
uh
goldie made i mean basically we were the
golden girls yeah yeah yeah yeah
you were dottie we like had different
names for each other until very recently
but we were old ladies we were because
we were old ladies you got it so early
vermont country store vermont country
change maybe they'll buy ads on the
podcast
you know what else they have they have
bloomers
sometimes a bloomer is a really nice
thing to have on under a summer dress
yeah okay
they're really covering i mean bridges
of madison county they're comfy
i mean i don't know i did i did actually
can you believe this is my best friend i
was going to bring you pickles too i've
started pickling
of course you have but i'm i'm really
into like food preserving but okay good
i need you to teach me how to be a wife
you know what in an apocalypse i think
i'd have us covered can you pick on my
face
i mean that's what right that's that's
what we're doing that's all i'm trying
to do
we could probably just do like some
vinegar i mean that's what it does it
doesn't
yeah no that's what's pickling right but
also but i hate to tell you this the
sugar
like counterintuitively the sugar is
what's preservative oh that's one point
there's a lot of sugar i mean the sugar
no because it takes forever
it's a different thing like i can do
like a marmalade in two days but
um and like a jam in the morning but
would she not be the biggest
influencer of all time if she did this
on instagram yeah you would
you'd have a stronghold i mean a legend
icon and star
and everyone had a darn don't you think
have you ever seen the pioneer woman
on instagram do you know the pioneer
yeah we know her we know the pioneer
woman
i really just want to live in the
country obviously i know but we got to
get you an instagram feed people did
make a lot of fun of me on because i
okay you're gonna see homesick blues
truly do you realize that this
so this liz astrologe pilot that i'm
doing yeah um i realized one day it's
the first
well it's one of the only jobs where i'm
not wearing like a corset or girdle
and like like actual stockings and high
heels and things but the reason i was
thinking about this is because
you don't have like wooden teeth yeah i
almost only do period work that's right
and so i get t's too then on sets
because i'll be sitting like knitting a
sweater in my period stuff
you know and like keep the cell phones
away even when you do a modern movie
that takes place now like he's just not
that into you
you're like dressed as pippy longstock
in the 20s
yeah you're in like a costume yeah i was
like oh my gosh in this show i'm gonna
actually be in like sneakers and workout
clothes and i am not so weird i'm not
gonna know what i told her the other day
i'm not gonna know what to do about the
fact that i'm
that i can go to the restroom like i can
go to the loo whenever i want
to dismantle because so yeah my work
life is kind
like the amount of water i drink is
dictated by my costumes you've always
been
in such crazy costumes i looked i
actually imdb'd myself the other day to
look because i was like no it can't be i
must have done something modern
but even like you know in once upon a
time i was my modern look was 60s
yeah and i mean i didn't have to wear a
corset for that stuff but um
for the modern stuff in that but it was
still like supposed to be like timeless
purity
but i almost have exclusively done
like 70s and before like a lot of 60s
and 50s and 40s right just wearing
and usually in a wig and i'm usually
just like old courses and crazy
and like pointy bras yes so it's so
weird to be like i'm gonna be in
sneakers i can just drink water
like acting's fun so much more
comfortable it's going to be a lot my
days are going to be a lot
shorter yes liz will make sure yeah but
i still sit on the set and like yeah so
i'll be like knitting a sweater and
yeah someone came around to me on a
project recently and they they taught me
what the
the term on brand meant
i think i had made people like meringues
and i was
very on brand very own brand that's very
i don't know what that it's very unbrand
for me to keep you for three hours
i'm gonna i promise my husband i have to
go take him i'm gonna show my horm
our husband our husband has a problem
call me he can call me if he has a
problem oh he will
um he'll call you i really want to post
uh
the photos from a friend of ours wedding
where we got drunk and he had a basket
on his head
and do you remember this you were
breastfeeding yeah i was not oh yeah
i was in a barn that's right thing
because it was the first time i'd ever
been away from my son
this is a friend of mine's wedding we
were in upstate hudson new york
jimmy was breast pumping on the planet
to be breast pumping in a dress in a
barn and near a bunch of pumpkins
on the plane i was doing it i remember
that and then josh and i got really
drunk
and he put a basket on his head and kept
this is so stupid and
no one's gonna think this is funny i was
just like dead in the bed and you guys
were laughing you were like
like two in the morning and you put a
basket on his head and he would take it
off that's right
he would go how did you get in here
i was i'm not allowed and i just got
breast implants and i and i
was afraid of my food we were both
having a brew
you were breastfeeding i was leaking
silicone and i was so afraid we're both
leaking we were hiding in that bar and
doing like halfway
i was so afraid i was like you're gonna
burst my boots
y'all are a little bit funny together
god the best yeah he has to come on here
oh he'd love it i don't think he's done
a podcast and he loves he listens to
that's all loves he does i know he's a
big part of the reason why i started a
podcast because
oh my god listen to these he's like
religiously he doesn't listen to music
he listens to
podcasts i know so cause i was like
you know he loves learning about people
i know because here's the thing i think
guys did podcasts first they were the
first out of the gate because they were
just born with more confidence guys are
like who wouldn't want to hear me talk
for three hours funny
and i was very like who would want to
hear me talk for three hours i have to
make it perfect and i have to like write
it all and
you know and then i was just like you
know i'm just gonna do what the boys do
i love it
that's what i like they just go where
the money is and i'm just going to
pretend i have the confidence and just
i do love your podcast i have listened
to some of them they're the only
podcasts
and he made me listen to the we were
talking about the he walked in the other
day and he was like he put his phone
down in front of me he's like you were
listening to ellen pompeo right
now on on because you are going to
relate
and you are going to idolize her yes i
like got a message to her yes
it's a great way to just like pilfer
wisdom from other people while you're
running errands and driving around yeah
like why would i mean parenting yes or
parenting or something or just like
you know um i feel like i just listened
to the ted talk podcast constantly i
listened to sam harris
i just oh he's gotten way into sam
harris is amazing
yeah i get all my news from joe rogan uh
we kind of way into john oliver that's
not a podcast yeah but no but i think he
has a
he has a podcast version oh i gotta tell
josh yes i'm sure josh knows
yes he's got an online life i don't know
what it is i know you're just a lot i
got kept in the basement i am i'm making
you i end these very awkwardly too
josh will tell you he what i end these
very awkwardly oh really
yeah there's nothing to plug except if
you're an emmy voter
obviously vote for ginny and dolly
parton we do get lots of like industry
people
nice i love you more than anything i
love you
[Laughter]
i'll see you next year on september 4th
my birthday
i mean i hope i'm going to see you like
oh before then i know but but you guys
will see her again yeah in here
done i love you hello how do you open my
present
oh yeah i mean it's by the way it really
is like pandemic like i feel
weird during the pandemic giving people
[Music]
presents
you